ओके। सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव।
अ
लेट्स सी।
लेट मी सेंड द अपडेट।
ओके तो अभी अ सभी लोगों को आने देते हैं
एंड लेट मी सेंड द अपडेट आल्सो गुड इवनिंग
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू वेरी
गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग
देखते हैं
और लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी मेनी पीपल आर
जॉइनिंग जल्दी से
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गाइस गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
ऑफ यू
ओके लेट मी सी लेट मी नो इफ आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली आप मुझे बता दीजिए एक
बार ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ सही है बिल्कुल
सही आ रही है सभी को आने देते हैं एक बार
थोड़ा वेट वेट करते हैं सभी ऑडियो वीडियो
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट सही
मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए एवरीबडी प्लीज लेट
मी नो ओके आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज वेल एंड
गुड
चलिए अ
ओके यस ऑल गुड ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है
बढ़िया बढ़िया
काफी कम लोग आए हैं अभी तो सबको एक बार
जॉइ करने देते देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग
हम ओके
ओके सो लेट एवरीबॉडी जॉइन नाउ एंड देन वी
विल स्टार्ट
ओके सो हियर नाउ 23 पीपल हैव जॉइ 20 22
लोग आ चुके हैं एंड आज जो है हम एक
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन जो है स्टार्ट करने वाले
वी विल बी ओनली स्टार्टिंग आवर प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन लेट्स सी
अ
ओके
चलिए ओके सो यस यस
मोबाइल गुम हो गया है तो पुलिस स्टेशन में
जाओ पुलिस स्टेशन में बताओ गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग फर्स्ट टाइम जॉइनिंग योर लाइव थैंक
यू थैंक यू वेरी मच
ग्रेट बढ़िया। ओके। सो बिफोर वी स्टार्ट
सबसे पहले
ओके। लाइव नहीं देख पाते। रिकॉर्डिंग
देखते हैं। ठीक है कोई बात नहीं। इट्स
फाइन। कोई बात नहीं। बट लाइव में जो मजा
है वो रिकॉर्डिंग में नहीं होती यार। मुझे
पता है ना मुझे। सो सबसे पहले फर्स्ट ऑफ
ऑल लेट मी अ शो यू Lindin पे आप सिंपली
हमारे Lindin पे जाके हमारे जल्दी-जल्दी
मैं आपको सोशल हैंडल्स हमारे बता देता
हूं। हमारी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी
का Lindin पेज है। हमारे कंपनी का पेज है।
सिंपली आप Lindin पे जाके डिफ़्रॉनिक्सic
सर्च करेंगे। यू विल गेट टू अ रीच दिस
पर्टिकुलर पेज जो कि हमारी कंपनी का है।
एंड यहां पे आपके साथ-साथ 20,000 और
डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए हैं।
एंड आप इनके साथ जुड़ सकते हैं। जो भी
कंपनी का अपडेट है, कैसे हम इस कंपनी को
स्केल कर रहे हैं। किस तरीके से हम
क्या-क्या चीजें हम लेकर आएंगे अपकमिंग
फ्यूचर में वो सारी चीजें आपको यहां पे
मिल जाएंगी। सो मस्ट फॉलो दिस आवर
पर्टिकुलर पेज। यहां पे आप मेरे से भी जुड़
सकते हैं। दिस इज़ माय प्रोफाइल ऑन
Lindin.com
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर एंड यू कैन जस्ट सेंड
मी द रिक्वेस्ट एंड यू कैन कनेक्ट विद मी।
राइट? दिस इज़ द थिंग। देन नेक्स्ट इज़ द
Instagram ऑफ़ आवरनिक्स Academy यू कैन
जस्ट गो एंड फॉलो अस देयर ऑन Instagram
फॉर डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ जो भी आपके इनेशन
रील्स आते हैं जो भी इनफेशन वीडियोस आती
है आपको सब इस पे जो है वो मिल जाता है।
एंड ये हमारा जो है वो Twitter पेज है
डेफ़on एकडमी का। यू कैन सिंपली जस्ट गो
देयर एंड फॉलो अस ऑन द Twitter। ये सब
आपको करने के कोई पैसे नहीं लगते हैं।
बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ़ कॉस्ट है। यू कैन जस्ट कम
एंड फॉलो अस। राइट? ओके। इन सबके पहले इन
सब एक सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज ये है कि आप
किसी भी हमारे किसी भी हमारे वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप चले जाइएगा। लाइक एनी
वीडियो डिस्क्रिप्शन। मैं यहां पे अगर
डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करता हूं हमारे YouTube
चैनल के। एंड लेट्स सपोज़ कि मैं अभी लाइव
सेक्शन में चलता हूं। आई एम गोइंग टू द
लाइव सेक्शन एंड लेट्स सपोज यह लाइव है या
कोई से भी लाइव सेक्शन का डिस्क्रिप्शन
ओपन कर लीजिए स्टार्ट दिस वन एबिलिटी
जस्ट ओपन द डिस्क्रिप्शन हियर एंड हियर यू
विल फाइंड WhatsApp चैनल लिंक इस चैनल
लिंक ये रहा सेकंड जो लिंक है आपका
WhatsApp चैनल लिंक आप इसको ओपन करके यहां
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा यहां पे बेसिकली हम जितने
भी अपडेट्स होते हैं रिगार्डिंग अपकमिंग
कोर्सेज फ्री ट्रेनिंग YouTube के अपडेट्स
सारी चीजें हर एक चीज सबसे पहले आपको इसी
चैनल पे मिल जाएगी एंड बग बंटी के एक
ग्रुप है हमारे WhatsApp के ऊपर में। आप
उसको भी जॉइ कर सकते हैं। फर्स्ट वाली जो
यह लिंक है WhatsApp की इसको इनेबल करके।
जैसे ही आप इसको क्लिक करते हैं, यू विल
गो एंड यू विल जॉइन द WhatsApp ग्रुप।
WhatsApp ग्रुप भी आप जॉइ कर सकते हैं। सो
दैट्स इट। आई होप कि आप सभी हमसे कनेक्ट
जरूर करेंगे। चलिए बिफोर वी स्टार्ट टुडे
सेशन मैं आपको एक चीज समझाना चाहता हूं।
मैं आपको एक चीज बताना चाहता हूं। आप सभी
को कि लास्ट जो हमने क्लास करी थी, द
लास्ट सेशन वी हैड वाज़ बेसिकली पार्ट वन
ऑफ़ दिस सेशन जो हमने लास्ट बग बाउंड्री की
क्लास करी थी। एंड इसीलिए ये जो सेशन है,
यह जल्दी लेकर मैं आया हूं। एंड यहां पे
जब हम आप YouTube चैनल पे जाएंगे। सो आई
विल गो टू द लाइव सेक्शन हियर। एंड इन द
लाइव सेक्शन यू विल सी कि हमने डे 58
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग करी थी।
एचटीटीp डिसिंग पार्ट वन। उसी का यह पार्ट
टू है। एंड इसीलिए मैं यह जो सेशन है
थोड़ी जल्दी लेकर आया हूं। क्योंकि कई लोग
पार्ट वन देखने के बाद पार्ट टू का वेट कर
रहे थे। कई लोगों ने मैसेज किए थे कि
थोड़ा जल्दी लेकर आ जाओ सर हमें प्रैक्टिस
करनी है। तो मैं ये लेकर आ गया हूं। अब एक
चीज मैं आपको क्लियर बताना चाहता हूं कि
जब आप एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग को पढ़
रहे हैं जब उसकी आप प्रैक्टिस कर रहे हैं।
तो याद रखिएगा दिस इज़ कंसीडर्ड एज वन ऑफ़ द
कॉम्प्लेक्स वलेबिलिटी। थोड़ी कॉम्प्लेक्स
कंसीडरेशन इसकी की जाती है इन अह साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी बट इट्स नॉट अ
इंपॉसिबल वनेबिलिटी जिसको कि आप समझ ही
नहीं सकते ऐसा नहीं है। इट कैन बी
कंसीडर्ड एज अ इजी वनेबिलिटी अगर आप इसको
समझ जाते हैं। अगर आप इसको अच्छे से समझ
जाते हैं, इसके कांसेप्ट को अच्छे से समझ
जाते हैं, देन इट विल बी मोस्ट इज़ियर फॉर
यू। आपको काफी मजा आएगा इस वनेबिलिटी को
फाइंड करने में। एंड अभी करेंटली हैकर वन
बक क्राउड जैसे प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे जब आप
जाएंगे तो इस वनेबिलिटी का यूज़ करके काफी
सारे एक्सप्लइट्स काफी सारे वलेबिलिटी जो
काफी सारे टारगेट्स हैं उनको एक्सप्लइट
किया जा रहा है एंड काफी अच्छी खासी P1 P2
की जो है इसकी आपको रैंकिंग मिल जाती है
एंड वनेबिलिटी का जो आप जब रिपोर्ट करेंगे
तो मोस्टली जो है वह क्रिटिकल हाई जो है
ज़ोन में आपकी फॉल करती है। तो आपका एक
चांस बढ़ता है बाउंटी को थोड़ा बढ़ाने का।
तो मैं आपसे बोलूंगा कि इस वनेबिलिटी को
थोड़ा पार्ट वन एंड पार्ट टू दोनों को
देखें। अगर आप एकदम बिल्कुल न्यू है तो
पार्ट वन को भी देखो। पार्ट वन टू को भी
देखो। पार्ट वन देख लिया है तो पार्ट टू
को एकदम बिल्कुल फोकस करके आपको रहना है।
अब पार्ट वन में मैंने आपको पूरी डिटेल
बताई थी इस वलेबिलिटी को लेके कि ये
वोलेबिलिटी एग्जैक्टली है क्या? मैं आपको
थोड़ा सा इसका रीकप कर देता हूं। मैंने
सिंपली यहां पे कांसेप्ट कोर कांसेप्ट्स
के थ्रू फ्रंट फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड
सर्वर के बारे में आपको बताया था। सर्वर
एक ही है बट वो क्या है कि एक फ्रंट एंड
में प्रॉक्सी सर्वर या सीडीएंस होते हैं
वो एंड फिर बैक एंड जो मेन सर्वर है। उसके
बाद मैंने ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग और कंटेंट
लेंथ के ऊपर बात की थी जो कि इसका सबसे
मेन टॉपिक है। बिल्डिंग ब्लॉक है इस पूरे
वनेबिलिटी को फाइंड करने की। ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग एंड कंटेंट लेंथ। इसी पे पूरा
गेम चलता है इस वलेबिलिटी का। उसके बाद
मैंने बताया था कंटेंट लेंथ क्या होता है?
कैसे का कैसे उसको एक्सप्रेस किया जाता
है? ट्रांसफर कोडिंग क्या होती है? ये
सारी चीजें बताई थी। एंड मैंने आपको और भी
बहुत सारे जो है इसके अलग-अलग जो
कांसेप्ट्स हैं वो आपको यहां पे दिखाए थे।
राइट? तो ये कांसेप्ट्स आपको यहां पे
डीसिंक का मतलब आपको बताया था। व्हाट इज़
डीसिंक देन आपको डीसिंक का डेमोंस्ट्रेशन
जो है वो करके आपको दिखाया था। देन आपको
एसटीडीp रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग कौन-कौन से
होते हैं? cl. T.cl, t. वो सब बताया था।
एंड इनको एक्सप्लेन भी करा था सारी चीजें।
आपको समझ में आई थी कि हां यह चीज़ कैसे
काम करती है। अब मुझे आपसे एक सवाल है। आप
सबसे जितने भी लोग यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं
ईमानदारी से जवाब अगर देंगे तो बढ़िया
रहेगा क्योंकि इट्स नॉट काइंड ऑफ़ कि आप
बच्चे हैं। सो जस्ट स्पीक ऑनेस्टली। अब
मैं यहां पे चैट सेक्शन पे आ चुका हूं। आई
एम जस्ट सीइंग द चैट सेक्शन कि आप लोगों
में से कितने लोगों ने जो फर्स्ट पार्ट है
उसको लाइव में कंप्लीट देखा या फिर लाइव
खत्म होने के बाद रिकॉर्डिंग देख के और
उसकी प्रैक्टिस करी है एग्जैक्टली लाइक
एग्जैक्टली यू हैव प्रैक्टिस्ड तो आप
लोगों में से कितने लोग हैं प्रैक्टिस
करके और समझने की कोशिश करी है हाउ मेनी
ऑफ यू
बताइए मुझे जस्ट वांट टू नो कितने लोग हैं
यहां पे
मतलब कैसे भी देखा हो लाइक देखा हो,
रिकॉर्डिंग देखी हो या कैसे भी देखा हो बट
हां देखा है
एट जस्ट मोर क्योंकि अभी प्रैक्टिकल
स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं तो इट्सेंट टू आस्क
ओके नहीं किया कुछ लोगों ने लाइव में देखा
है। कुछ लोगों ने रिकॉर्डिंग भी देखी है।
कुछ लोगों ने कंप्लीट करा है। अब देखो अगर
अगर आप अगर आप इसको प्रैक्टिस नहीं करेंगे
इस वनेबिलिटी को तो इस वनेबिलिटी में आपको
कुछ समझ में नहीं आने वाला है। लिटरली मैं
आपको बता रहा हूं इट विल जस्ट गेट गो आउट
ऑफ योर माइंड एंड आपके दिमाग मतलब ऊपर ऊपर
से चला जाएगा आपके दिमाग के और अंदर
घुसेगा नहीं आपके दिमाग में। ये इतनी
इंपॉर्टेंट वनेबिलिटी है। तो यू शुड
डेफिनेटली गो एंड कंप्लीट दिस वनेबिलिटीज़
वीडियोस। उस दोनों वीडियोस को आपको
कंप्लीट करने हैं। अभी आपको प्रैक्टिकल
सेशन जो है वो देखने हैं क्योंकि अभी अभी
आपका कुछ नहीं जा रहा प्रैक्टिकल सेशन में
देखने में। इट्स नॉर्मल। सो व्हाट आई एम
गोइंग टू डू आई एम जस्ट गोइंग टू द
सेटिंग्स देन गोइंग टू द नेटवर्क सेटिंग्स
देन नो प्रॉक्सी। ओके एंड लेट्स ओपन
फोर्थ स्वीकर। ओके। सो मैं ये ओपन कर लेता
हूं। एकडमी ओपन कर लेते हैं।
एंड लेट्स सी। चलिए अब हम आ चुके हैं यहां
पे। एंड दिस इज़ लेटेस्ट टॉपिक वी आर गोइंग
टू द रिक्वेस्ट एचटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग
टॉपिक एंड आई एम हियर नाउ अब इसके
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन हम बबूट पे
देखेंगे एंड मैं आपको समझाऊंगा क्योंकि आप
पोर्ट फिगर के जो लैब है ना लैब जैसे ये
मान लो मैं आपको दो लैब आज करा दूंगा ये
जो पहला लैब है दूसरा लैब है ये आप कर भी
लेंगे ना पोर्ट फिगर से कहीं से देख के या
कुछ करके तो भी आपको समझ में मोस्टली जो
है वो नहीं आने वाला है मतलब कर तो लेंगे
आप हो सकता है लैब सॉल्व भी कर ले लेकिन
आपको बैक बैकग्राउंड में जो कांसेप्ट आ
रही है वो शायद ना समझ में आए। मुझे ऐसा
लगता है कई लोगों के साथ ऐसा होगा। कई
लोगों ने पहले सॉल्व करने की कोशिश की
होगी बट उनका सॉल्व या तो नहीं हो पाया
होगा और हो भी गया होगा ना तो बाद में
उनके दिमाग में कंफ्यूजन क्रिएट हुए
होंगे। बाद में वो सोच में पड़ गए होंगे
कि अरे यार ये हुआ कैसे है? ये ये इस
तरीके से आखिर ये डेटा कंटेंट लेंथ का
यहां क्या मतलब है? ये इतना कंटेंट लेंथ
का क्या रोल है? ये पार्ट कहां गया? ये
कैसे आ गया? मतलब जी पोस्ट कैसे आ गई? ये
सारी चीजें हैं। ये सच है कि नहीं है? सच
बताओ मुझे। मुझे बताओ ऐसा है। ऐसा है जो
मैं बोल रहा हूं ऐसा लिटरली
अ जो मैंने बोला अभी ऐसा है बहुत लोगों के
साथ कि सॉल्व भी कर लिया हो क्योंकि
सॉल्यूशन वगैरह देख के या जो भी गए करके
बट स्टिल दिमाग जो है वो क्वेश्चंस कर रहे
हैं आपके कि भैया ये कैसे हो गया है? ये
थोड़ा सा कॉम्प्लेक्स थोड़ी सी है
कॉम्प्लेक्सिटी। इसी वजह से ये चीजें होनी
है। मतलब कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। दिस इज अ
नॉर्मल थिंग। राइट? सही बात है सर। बढ़िया।
बढ़िया।
हां। ठीक है। तो चलिए तो अभी काफी लोगों
के दिमाग में होता है। चलिए अब यहां पे
मैं आ जाता हूं यहां पे। सबसे पहले द
फर्स्ट थिंग जिस पे हम आ रहे हैं वो है
हमारा पहला लैब एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगलिंग बेसिक clte वनेबिलिटी तो पहला
लैब है हमारा clte वबिलिटी ठीक है clte
वनेबिलिटी जो हम यहां पे करने वाले हैं
हमने जो पढ़ा था ना उसी के बेसिस पे
करेंगे तो हम clt clt वबिलिटी के ऊपर आ
जाते हैं जो हमने पहले किया था दिस वन
राइट clt वलेबिलिटी अब ये clt वलेबिलिटी
में मैंने आपको बताया था कि सीl पहले है
तो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर कंटेंट लेंथ को प्रेफर
करेगा एंड जो बैक एंड है वह कहां पे फॉल
बैक करेगा ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग पे करेगा बस
यही पूरा का पूरा कांसेप्ट है और इसमें
मैंने आपको बताया था कुछ इस तरीके से कि
ज़ीरो यहां पे जो है ट्रांसफर कोडिंग चंक
डेटा यहां पे टर्मिनेट हो गई है। और उसके
बाद ये 13 जो कंटेंट लेंथ 13 यहां पे दिया
हुआ है। एंड यहां पे ये आपको कितना मिल
रहा है? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 एट मिल रही है।
इट्स नॉट इवन 13 तो ये इसी तरीके से कैसे
फिर इसको ये आगे फॉरवर्ड करेगा। हाउ इट
विल फॉरवर्ड अहेड एंड किस तरीके से ये काम
करेगा वो सारी चीजें हम इसमें देखने वाले
हैं जिसका नाम है clt टैग। चलिए अब इसमें
यहां पे जो लैब है इसको समझने से पहले एक
चीज़ इंपॉर्टेंट ये है कि लैब के
डिस्क्रिप्शन को जरूर पढ़िएगा। क्या है लैब
में डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या है वो आपको
थोड़ी जानकारी हो जाएगी एंड clt
वेलेबिलिटी का कांसेप्ट एकदम बिल्कुल
क्लियर हो जाएगा राइट हां सर ये भी
बताइएगा कि कैसे पता करें कि कौन सा सर्वर
क्या चेक करेगा cl या टीई नहीं नहीं देखो
देखो देखो ये ये तुम्हें पता करना है ये
तुम्हें उसको फाइंड करना है तुम्हें फाइंड
किस लिए करना है कैसे करना है उसकी आउटपुट
के अकॉर्डिंग ये यू हैव टू कंफर्म इट थ्रू
द आउटपुट कि सर्वर क्या यूज़ कर रहा है या
जो बैक एंड सर्वर है वो वो क्या यूज़ कर
रहा है? फ्रंट एंड सर्वर क्या यूज़ कर रहा
है? वो भी मैं बताऊंगा। सो यस ठीक है। मैं
वो भी आपको समझाऊंगा कि कैसे आप कंफर्म
करेंगे कि बैक एंड क्या यूज़ कर रहा है
एग्जैक्टली। एंड बैक एंड अगर वो एक यूज़
नहीं कर रहा तो तो दूसरा यूज़ कर रहा होगा
और फ्रंट एंड उसका अपोजिट यूज़ कर रहा
होगा। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। ठीक है? चलिए
हम उसको भी देखेंगे। सो cl.t अ के
कांसेप्ट में आप सबको ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ
था।
cl.t के कांसेप्ट में मैंने आपको बताया
हुआ था कि हियर द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर यूजज़ द
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड द बैक एंड सर्वर
यूज़ज़ द ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर। बस यही
मैंने आपको पूरा का पूरा कांसेप्ट बताया
था। अब इस कांसेप्ट पे आते हैं। कांसेप्ट
को अब समझते हैं कि इस तरीके का एक
रिक्वेस्ट जाता है। द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
प्रोसेससेस द कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर एंड
डिटरमाइन दैट द रिक्वेस्ट बॉडी इज़ 13 बाइट
लॉन्ग। अप टू द एंड ऑफ़ स्मगल्ड। ये 13
बाइट लॉन्ग है। अब ये 13 कैसे है इसका भी
मैंने आपको समझाया था। बट अभी फिर से वापस
से रिपीट करूंगा तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगी।
ये सारी चीजें जब आप देखेंगे तभी समझ में
आएगी। देखो थोड़ी कॉम्प्लेक्स देखो कितनी
अ कितनी वो है एक
इस चीज को नोटिस करो आप लोग कि थोड़ी सी
कॉम्प्लेक्स थोड़ी सी कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक
आई है। एंड लोग है ही नहीं। मतलब बग बंटी
के सेशन में हमेशा 50 से ऊपर लाइव अटेंड
करते हैं। ये नॉर्मल है। बट क्यों नहीं
अटेंड कर रहे हैं इस टॉपिक में? क्योंकि
लोगों को कॉम्प्लेक्स लग रहा है ये टॉपिक।
मैं ये कहना चाह रहा हूं कि अगर आप
कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक को समझने की कोशिश नहीं
करोगे। अगर आप उसको बार-बार रिपीट नहीं
करोगे, बार-बार उसको प्रैक्टिस नहीं करोगे
तो कैसे समझोगे? फिर तो आप छोड़ दोगे। हार
मान जाओगे। अगर हार ही माननी है फिर तो
कोई बात ही नहीं है। राइट? यू डोंट हैव
टू। राइट? चलिए। दिस लैब इनवॉल्व्स अ
फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर एज यूजुअल
एंड द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर डज़ नॉट सपोर्ट
चंग्ड इनकोडिंग। इसमें इन्होंने बता रखा
है कि फ्रंट एंड सर्वर चंग्ड इनकोडिंग
सपोर्ट नहीं करता। कंटेंट लेंथ सपोर्ट
करता है जो कि clt को जस्टिफाई करता है कि
कंटेंट लेंथ फ्रंट एंड सर्वर टीई क्या है?
बैक एंड सर्वर। द फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
रिजेक्ट्स रिक्वेस्ट दैट आर नॉट यूजिंग
गेट और पोस्ट मेथड। मतलब गेट और पोस्ट
मेथड अगर यूज़ नहीं है तो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
उसको रिजेक्ट कर देगा। टू सॉल्व द लैब,
स्मगल अ रिक्वेस्ट टू द बैक एंड सर्वर। इस
लैब को सॉल्व करने के लिए बैक एंड सर्वर
को एक रिक्वेस्ट को स्मगल करना है।
तुम्हें एक रिक्वेस्ट अंदर लेके जाना है।
सो दैट द नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट प्रोसेस्ड बाय
द बैक एंड सर्वर अपीयरर्स टू यूज़ द मेथड
जी पोस्ट। ताकि अगला जो है जी पोस्ट मेथड
को यूज़ करता हुआ दिखे। जब वो रिक्वेस्ट
स्मगल हो जाए तो जो सर्वर है बैक एंड वाला
वो जी पोस्ट मेथड को यूज़ करे। एंड जब जी
पोस्ट मेथड को यूज़ करेगा तो उस समय क्या
आएगी आपके पास सामने कि दिस इज़ नॉट अ
वैलिड मेथड। दिस इज़ नॉट अ वैलिड मेथड
क्योंकि जी पोस्ट नाम का कोई मेथड नहीं
होता है। मेथड पोस्ट होते हैं, मेथड गेट
होता है। एचटीटीपी मेथड्स की मैं बात कर
रहा हूं। डिलीट होता है, पुट होता है। ये
सब मेथड्स हैं। जी पोस्ट कोई मेथड नहीं
है। तो अगर कहीं से सर्वर के साइड से ये
रिस्पांस आ गया कि इनवैलिड मेथड जे जी
पोस्ट इसका मतलब है सर्वर के पास जी पोस्ट
पहुंच चुका है। बस इतना ही हमें समझना है।
और यही लैब का काम है। अब देखो इसका
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या है? ऑलदो द लैब
सपोर्ट्स एचटीटीp टू द इंटेंडेंट सॉल्यूशन
रिक्वायर्स टेक्निक्स दैट आर ओनली पॉसिबल
विथ एचटीटीp वन। मतलब ये लैब एसटी टू
एचटीटीp टू वर्जन टू को भी सपोर्ट करता
है। बट एचटीटीp वन पे ही यह पॉसिबल है।
ठीक है? तो हमें इसको मैनुअली जो है
डाउनग्रेड करना पड़ेगा। तो हम डाउनग्रेड
भी करेंगे।
अब देखिए यहां पे हम एक्सेस द लैब करते
हैं।
ओके वी आर नाउ एक्सेसिंग द लैब।
सो द लैब इज़ ओपनिंग हियर। नाउ लेट्स
लेट इट ओपन। चलिए, यह ओपन हो चुकी है। अब
मैं बबूट को ओपन कर लेता हूं। सो, आई एम
यूजिंग द बबूट वर्जन 2024
ओके। सो लेट्स इट ओपन।
चलिए। सो इट्स ओपनिंग।
ये सेम चीज़ आप लाइव टारगेट पे ट्राई कर
सकते हैं। सेम प्रोसेस है। सब कुछ सिमिलर
तरीके से आप कर सकते हैं। आइडेंटिफाई करने
का मैं बता दूंगा कंफर्म करने का। उससे
आपका थोड़ा सा क्लेरिटी आपको मिल जाएगी।
राइट? चलिए अब यहां पे हम आ चुके हैं। अब
हम यहां पे टारगेट पे चलते हैं। एंड यहां
पे हम प्रॉक्सी पे चल के इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ
कर देते हैं। नाउ गो टू द अ ब्राउज़र।
लेट्स रीलोड इट एंड एसटीडीp हिस्ट्री पे
चलेंगे। हमारा जो भी टारगेट है हम उसको
चूज़ करेंगे। सो रीलोड करने के चलो रीलोड
तो कर दिया बट हमने बर्ब की प्रॉक्सी
कॉन्फ़िगर नहीं करी है Firefox में। तो एक
बार प्रॉक्सी वाली चेक कर लेते हैं
नेटवर्क सेटिंग्स में। मैनुअल प्रॉक्सी
बर्ब की प्रॉक्सी यहां पे करके ओके कर
देते हैं। नाउ वी कैन रीलोड इट टू गेट इट
पॉपुलेटेड अंडर द एचटीp हिस्ट्री। तो हमने
रीलोड किया। ये एचटीपी हिस्ट्री में
पॉपुलेट हो रही है। आप देख सकते हैं जो भी
रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे और मेन रिक्वेस्ट
हमें मिल गई है ये वाली जिस पे हम ये पूरी
अ जो clt वनेबिलिटी है उसको हम फाइंड करने
की कोशिश करेंगे। सो clt वनेबिलिटी को
फाइंड करने का या इस टाइप के एसटीp
रिक्वेस्ट वनेबिलिटी को फाइंड करने के
मेथड तरीके क्या होते हैं? मैं आपको बताता
हूं। चार स्टेप्स होते हैं जनरली। द
फर्स्ट स्टेप इज़ डिटेक्ट। पहला जो होता है
वो डिटेक्ट करना होता है इस वनबिलिटी को
जिससे कि जिसको कि टाइमिंग एनालिसिस बोलते
हैं। एक टाइमिंग एनालिसिस के थ्रू यू कैन
एक्चुअली डिटेक्ट द मेथड कि ये एक्चुअली
है कि नहीं इसमें। फिर कंफर्म करना होता
है कि भैया कंफर्म करो पोइजन करके देन
एक्सप्लोर एंड एक्सप्लइट। ये आगे के
प्रोसेससेस होते हैं। तो हमें यहां पे
डिटेक्ट एंड कंफर्म इज़ द वेरी वेरी मेन
थिंग कि डिटेक्ट करना जिससे कि टाइमिंग
एनालिसिस। मतलब सर्वर अगर थोड़े टाइम के
लिए रिस्पांस देना बंद कर दे रहा है। थोड़े
टाइम बाद रुक के थोड़ा टाइम डिले करके
रिस्पांस दे रहा है। इसका मतलब है सर्वर
के पास कुछ इनवैलिड चीजें पहुंच चुकी है।
जिसके कारण वो टाइम ले रहा है और फिर उसके
बाद बोल रहा है कि नहीं भैया अब मेरे बस
की बात नहीं है। खत्म करो इसको। एंड वो
अपना खत्म कर दे रहा है। उसके बाद कंफर्म
कि भैया सच में वो जो पोइजन डेटा है जो
मलेशियस डाटा है वो पहुंच गई है। दैट्स
इट।
अब चलिए अब यहां पे देखते हैं
बबशूट में वी आर हियर। दिस रिक्वेस्ट हैज़
बीन कैप्चरर्ड। अब इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम
सेंड करते हैं रिपीटर को। ठीक है? हमने
यहां पे रिपीटर को सेंड कर दिया। वी आर ऑन
द रिपीटर हियर। रिपीटर पे हम आ चुके हैं।
दैट्स इट। चलिए यह रिपीटर पर आ गया। अब यह
जो रिक्वेस्ट है इसको हम समझते हैं।
इसको हम समझते हैं स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट। वी आर
टेकिंग इट एज स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट। एंड एक और
रिक्वेस्ट हम लेते हैं नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट
सेंड टू रिपीटर। फिर से करते हैं इसको।
एंड इसको हम करते हैं रिक्वेस्ट नंबर टू
को नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट। तो हमने यहां पे दो
रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो दो रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे
रिपीटर में भेजे हैं। एक जो स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट के नाम से कर दिया। एक नॉर्मल
रिक्वेस्ट के नाम से कर दिया। ठीक है? तो
ये दोनों दो रिक्वेस्ट है। बस इतना अभी
आपको समझ के रखना है। दैट्स इट। इससे
ज्यादा अभी आपको नहीं समझना है। अब यहां
पे सबसे पहली चीज जो करनी है जो देखनी है
हमें क्या है कि
इसको पढ़ना है
मैनुअली फिक्सिंग द फील्ड्स। ठीक है? ये
चीज़ करके यहां पे आ रहा है कि एचटीटीपी टू
पे नहीं होना चाहिए। एचटीटीp वन पे होना
चाहिए। ठीक है? एंड मैनुअली फिक्सिंग द
लेंथ फील्ड्स। तो यह एक लेंथ फिट मतलब आप
फिक्स करने का एक यहां पे यह बोल रहे हैं
एक्सटेंशन डालिए। इसकी जरूरत नहीं है
हमें। हमें कोई दिक्कत नहीं। हमारा मेन
मोटिव होना चाहिए कि जी पोस्ट यूज़ होना
चाहिए। दैट्स इट। बस इसके और कुछ भी नहीं।
जब सॉल्यूशन में आप जाएंगे तो सॉल्यूशन
में इन्होंने बहुत छोटा सा सॉल्यूशन दे
रखा है यहां पे जो आपको ज्यादा समझ में
शायद नहीं आएगी। सीधा इन्होंने लिखा है कि
जो इस पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को दो बार
भेजिए। इशू द रिक्वेस्ट ट्वाइस। एंड आपके
पास ये रिप्लाई आना चाहिए सर्वर की तरफ से
अनरकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट क्योंकि जी
पोस्ट ये तभी भेज रहे हैं ना
अनरकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड क्योंकि इन्होंने जी
पोस्ट से इंटरेक्ट कर लिया जी पोस्ट उनके
तक पहुंच गई है और यही हमारा मेन मोटिव है
इसका तो अब इसको थोड़ा सा क्लियरली समझते
हैं कि ये बस इससे कुछ नहीं होना है इसको
समझना पड़ेगा तो फर्स्ट थिंग जो हम करने
वाले हैं जब हमारे पास स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट आई
है इसके पास हम चलते हैं सबसे पहली चीज जब
आप एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग में इस
तरह की प्रॉब्लम्स के साथ डील कर रहे होते
तो आपको सबसे पहला चीज करना है कि एचटीटीp
अगर टू है तो उसको डाउनग्रेड करना है वन
में। ये आप कहां से कर सकते हैं? राइट
साइड में यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट एट्रिब्यूट्स
का ऑप्शन मिलेगा। यहां पे जब आप इसको
एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो यहां पे एचटीटीपी वन
एचटीटीपी टू ऑप्शन मिलता है। आप एचटीटीपी
वन पे क्लिक करेंगे तो ये ऑटोमेटिकली
डाउनग्रेड हो जाएगा एचटीटीपी वन में।
हालांकि इसमें इस पर्टिकुलर सिनेरियो में
मेरे सिनेरियो में ये ऑलरेडी एचटीटीपी वन
पे है। तो यू डोंट नीड टू डू। बट अगर आपके
पास यहां एचटीटीपी स्लैश टू लिखा रहे तो
मतलब वो वर्जन टू में है। यू हैव टू
डाउनग्रेड फर्स्ट। पहला चीज। दूसरा चीज
हमें इस रिक्वेस्ट को जो गेट रिक्वेस्ट है
इसको पोस्ट में चेंज करना पड़ेगा। ऐसा
क्यों है? व्हाई दिस सो? बिकॉज़ हमें बॉडी
में कोई इंफॉर्मेशनेशन भेजनी है। हमें
डेटा भेजना है सर्वर के पास। और बॉडी में
डेटा तभी जाती है जब वो पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
के थ्रू जाती है। गेट के थ्रू नहीं जाएगी।
समझ में आ रहा है? तो यहां पे हमें इसको
राइट क्लिक करके चेंज्ड रिक्वेस्ट मेथड।
इस पे क्लिक करना है। चेंज रिक्वेस्ट
मेथड। जैसे ही इस पे क्लिक करेंगे, दिस
होल रिक्वेस्ट विल गेट कनवर्टेड टू पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट। तो मैं चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड
करूंगा। देखो यहां पे पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट बन
चुकी है। पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जैसे ही बन गई
यहां पे कंटेंट टाइप हेडर ऐड हो गया।
कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर ऐड हो गया। क्योंकि बॉडी
में मैसेज जब भेजेंगे तो उसका कुछ लेंथ
होगा। तो यहां पे इन्होंने वो चीज कर दी
है। बहुत सिंपल।
इतना सब कुछ हो गया। वी जस्ट डीड
एवरीथिंग। अब यहां पे हमारे पास बहुत सारे
हेडर्स हैं। कचरा भरा पड़ा है इन हेडर्स
के बीच में। अब इन हेडर्स में हमारे काम
का कुछ ही हेडर हैं जिसको हम यहां यूज़ में
लेने वाले हैं। बाकी सब बेकार के हेडर्स
हैं। तो इसका मतलब यह हुआ कि हम यहां पे
ये कंटेंट लेंथ हेडर इज़ेंट। कंटेंट टाइप
हेडर इज़ेंट। उसके बाद ये सारे हेडर्स की
कोई मतलब नहीं है। कोई काम का नहीं है। तो
इसको हम यहां से हटा सकते हैं। इनफैक्ट
होस्ट के नीचे तक का सब कुछ हटा सकते हैं।
कुकी यूजर एजेंट ये सब जो भी है ना सब हटा
दो। दीज़ एक्चुअली डज़ नॉट रिक्वायर्ड इज़
नॉट रिक्वायर्ड। हमने इसको हटा दिया।
दैट्स इट। अब हमारे पास चार हेडर बचे हैं।
मतलब बेसिकली एक मेथड है जो कि दिख रहा है
आपको। होस्ट हेडर दिख रही है आपको। कंटेंट
टाइप हेडर दिख रहा है एंड कंटेंट लेंथ
हेडर दिख रहा है। दैट्स इट। ये सब कुछ ओके
है। सब कुछ चल रहा है अपना। अब यहां से
असली गेम शुरू होता है। द रियल गेम बिगिंस
हियर। व्हाट इज द रियल गेम? रियल गेम क्या
है? ये आप सोचिए। आप आप आपको जब मैं कोई
चीज बताऊं ना मैं मतलब देख रहा हूं चैट
में अ
क्या होता है कि कई लोग चैट पे ज्यादा
ध्यान देते हैं तो जब मैं कोई चीज बता रहा
हूं तो आप लोग चैट को छोड़ो अभी साइड में
हो जाओ ठीक है और इस चीज पे फोकस करो बस
मैं इतना ही बोलूंगा इफ यू विल फोकस ऑन
दिस दैट्स इट आपका काम यहां पे हो जाएगा
अब मैं यहां पे बताता हूं द रियल गेम अब
मैं यहां पे इसको अगर सेंड करूंगा पता है
क्या होगा 200 ओके करके आ रहा है एंड एंड
योर रिस्पांस इज़ कमिंग। दैट्स ग्रेट। अब
मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं? व्हाट आई एम
गोइंग टू डू एज़ दिस इज़ cl डॉट वन एबिलिटी।
यानी कि फ्रंट एंड कंटेंट लेंथ को
प्रायोरिटाइज कर रहा है। दैट्स इट। कंटेंट
लेंथ को। तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे?
अब एक चीज़ डालता हूं। ट्रांसफर एक हेडर
डालता हूं।
ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग एंड ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंग्ड।
ठीक है? अब ट्रांसफर इंकोडिंग चंक्डर
मैंने डाल दिया क्योंकि सर्वर ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को यहां पे प्रायोरिटाइज करेगा
जब फ्रंट एंड आपका कंटेंट लेंथ को करेगा
तो तो मैंने यहां पे ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
डाल दिया। अब द नेक्स्ट थिंग इज़ यहां पे
एक बहुत बड़ा रोल है आपका
स्लश nr
r n का। स्लश RN का बहुत बड़ा रोल है। नाउ
व्हाट इज़ दिस? एग्जैक्टली अगर मैं आपको
यहां पे दिखाऊं स्लश RN
यहां पे एंड यहां पे मैं आपको दिखाऊं दिस
इज़ द स्लश RN
दिस इज़ राइट। सो इफ यू विल सी इफ यू विल
रीड एंड समथिंग लाइक दैट। तो दीज़ आर कॉल्ड
CR एलएफ जो कि बोलते हैं कि कैरज़ रिटर्न
एंड लाइन फीड इसको बोला जाता है। तो CR +
LF इसको लिखा जाता है। ठीक है? तो यूज़ दैट
अ न्यू लाइन कररेक्टर इन विंडज़ इन विंडोज़
या व्हाटएवर कहीं पे भी किसी भी जगह पे।
अब ये जो है ना आर सैश R n इनको हम नॉन
प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स भी बोलते हैं। नॉन
प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स क्यों बोलते हैं?
ऐसे कररेक्टर्स जो प्रिंट नहीं होते हैं।
तो ये ऑप्शन यहां पे आपको स्लैश एन का एक
दिखेगा। यहां पे जब इस पे होवर करोगे ना
माउस को तो यहां लिखा रहेगा शो नॉन
प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स। अब ये नॉन
प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर जो हैं हर लाइन के
लास्ट में लग जाते हैं लेकिन काउंट होते
हैं। प्रिंटेबल नहीं है। कोई मतलब नहीं है
उनका। कॉपी भी नहीं होगा आपका। लेकिन क्या
होगा? वो काउंट होते हैं। कैरेक्टर काउंट
होता है उनका। ये एक बड़ी इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
है। तो अब मैं अगर आपको यहां पे दिखाऊंगा
ये स्लैश एन को ऑन करके तो देखना कैसे लुक
चेंज होगा आपका। मैंने इसको नॉन प्रिंटेबल
जो कररेक्टर्स है इसको मैं शो करता हूं।
जैसे ही मैंने शो करा यू कैन सी हियर कि
यहां पे चंग्ड के बाद स्लश आर एन जीरो के
बाद स्लश आर एन ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग के बाद
यहां न्यू लाइन पे स्लैश आर एन पोस्ट के
बाद स्लैश आर एन होस्ट के बाद स्लैश आर एन
ये सारी चीजें आ रही हैं। तो यू कैन सी कि
व्हाट इज़ एग्जैक्टली हैपनिंग। राइट? अब
यहां पे पोस्ट के बाद जैसे पहली लाइन है
आर एन। दूसरी लाइन है आरएन। जैसे ही इसको
आप ऑफ करोगे ये सारे गायब हो जाएंगे।
एवरीथिंग विल बी गॉन। खत्म।
इट्स गॉन। राइट? तो ये जो चीज है यह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले क्यों करती है? मैं
आपको अभी बताऊंगा। जब मैं इसको ऑन करूंगा
यहां पे आप देखोगे स्लैश r n तो अब देखो
यहां पे ये जो चंग््ड है चंग्ड। अभी देखो
जैसे मैं इसको हटा देता हूं। मैं इसको
जस्ट रिमूविंग इट। अब अगर मुझे कोई बोलेगा
कि भैया ये सी एच यू एन के ई डी ये कितने
कररेक्टर्स हैं? तो मैं कैसे बताऊंगा?
इसको सेलेक्ट करूंगा। इसको जब मैं इसको
सेलेक्ट करूंगा तो यहां राइट साइड में
इंस्पेक्टर में आपको कितने कररेक्टर दिख
रहे हैं? मुझे बताइए। आपको कितने कररेक्टर
दिख रहे हैं? हाउ मेनी कररेक्टर यू आर
सीइंग? इंस्पेक्टर में ये मुझे बता दीजिए।
हाउ मेनी कररेक्टर यू आर सीइंग?
लेट मी नो।
सभी लोग बताइए कितने कररेक्टर्स आप देख
रहे हैं?
सेवन। सो इट्स सेवन कररेक्टर। राइट?
एवरीवन हैव टू
हैव टू टाइप इन द चैट सेक्शन। 40 लोग हैं
लाइक ठोक दो और टाइप कर दो जल्दी से। सात
दिख रहे हैं आपको। यहां पे राइट में
इंस्पेक्टर वाले में सेवन दिखेगा आपको। ये
देखो।
ठीक है? 0x7 वो इसका हेक्साडेसिमल फॉर्मेट
है। तो वो दिख रहा है आपको हेक्साडेसिमल
वे और ये आपका डेसिमल जो है सात दिख रहा
है। ओके। अब मैं यहां पे क्या करूंगा?
प्रिंटेबल नॉन प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स जो है
इसको मैं इनेबल करूंगा। आई एम जस्ट
इनेबलिंग नॉन प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर एंड जैसे
ही मैं इनेबल करूंगा यहां पे फॉरवर्ड
स्लैश जो भी है आर एन यहां पे आ जाएगा जो
आपका सीआरआरएफ अ जो आपका बेसिकली यहां पे
अ सीआरएलएफ जो आपका एक नॉन प्रिंटिंग
कररेक्टर या जिसका कोई मतलब नहीं है
बेसिकली लेकिन काउंट होते हैं तो वो कैरज
रिटर्न एंड लाइन फीड। ठीक है? तो सीआर
एलएफ यहां पे आ जाएगा। अब मैं इसको अगर
सेलेक्ट करूंगा ना तो अब देखो कितने काउंट
हो रहे हैं। हाउ मेनी काउंट आर देयर?
अब बताइए मुझे सभी लोग एवरीबॉडी प्लीज लेट
मी नो हाउ मेनी कररेक्टर्स आर देयर?
लेट मी नो हाउ मेनी कररेक्टर्स आर देयर?
नाउ नाइन। अब समझ में आ रहा है RN का
मतलब? RN का यहां पे फार्मूला समझ में आया
आपको?
व्हाट इज दिस RN?
हम गॉट इट इतना क्लियर हुआ
बताइए मुझे इज इट क्लियर
rn वाला फार्मूला समझ में आया ना कितना
खतरनाक फार्मूला है चलो अभी देखते हैं हां
अभी देखते हैं अभी इसका मतलब क्या है अभी
देखते हैं अब यहां पे जब मैंने एक न्यू
लाइन करा ना न्यू लाइन मैं अब यहां पे
करके एंटर करूंगा तो एक और आर एन आ जाएगा
एक और एंड आर एंटर एंटर एंटर न्यू लाइन पे
हर न्यू लाइन पे भी आपका आरएन जो है वो
आता चला जाएगा। दिस इज़ आल्सो काउंटेड। यह
भी आपका काउंट होता है। अंटिल एंड अनलेस
इट इज़ एसोसिएटेड विद सम काइंड ऑफ़ हेडर।
अगर हेडर के साथ एसोसिएटेड है ना, तो उस
हेडर के लिए काउंट नहीं होगा। जैसे कि मैं
क्या कहना चाह रहा हूं? जैसे यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो है। तो, इसके साथ जो
आरएन है ना, यह कंटेंट लेंथ के लिए काउंट
नहीं होगा। इसके नीचे से जो चीजें हैं ना
जो दूसरी हेडर के अलावा जो अ एक्चुअल बाइट
है वो काउंट होगा। जैसे कंटेंट लेंथ के
लिए आपका ये 0 n काउंट नहीं होगा। ये जो
चीज है ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग वाली चीज ये
काउंट नहीं होगी। लेकिन लेकिन ये rn काउंट
होगा। जो rn है काउंट होगा। तो यहां पे
अगर मैं आपसे अभी पूछूं करेंटली कि अभी इस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट में कंटेंट लेंथ
कितने बाइट का है? तो मुझे बताइए कितना
है? तभी अभी मैं समझ जाऊंगा कि आप लोगों
को कितना समझ में आया। सभी लोग बताइए,
आंसर कीजिए। लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर
आंसरिंग करेक्ट। सो व्हाट इज द कंटेंट
लेंथ हियर? लेट मी नो। कंटेंट लेंथ सभी
लोग बताइए। आई वांट आंसर फ्रॉम एवरीबॉडी।
कंटेंट लेंथ एक्चुअली इज टू। यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ टू ही है। मैंने आपको पहले ही
बोला कि हेडर के आरएन जो है आपका वो
कंसीडर नहीं किए जाते हैं। जो मैसेस बॉडी
के अंदर में है अदर देन अदर हेडर्स तो
उसको हम यहां पे काउंट किए जाते हैं। सो
इट्स ट्रू। ठीक है? अब देखो यहां तो ये
काम हो गया। बट अब हम अपने उस चीज से भटक
रहे हैं जो हमारा मेन मोटिव है। लेकिन ये
उसी का पार्ट है। इसको बिना समझे यू कैन
नेवर अंडरस्टैंड व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू।
सो अब मैं आ जाता हूं यहां पे वापस से। अब
यहां पे इन्होंने क्या किया है? एक जीरो
एक जी ये सब दे दिया है। तो इसको हम यहां
पे अभी फिलहाल नहीं देंगे। हम यहां पे
अपने हिसाब से करेंगे। तो हमने यहां पे
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंक्ड किया। कंटेंट
लेंथ को हमने अभी भी ज़ीरो ही रखा है।
बिकॉज़ जैसे पहले आया था वैसे ही रख दिया।
अब यहां जो सेंड ऑप्शन है उसके बगल में एक
सेटिंग का ऑप्शन है। इस पे क्लिक करेंगे
ना आप तो यहां पे एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा अपडेट
कंटेंट लेंथ। ये टिक्ड मार्क है। या टिक
मार्क का मतलब ये हुआ कि जैसे-जैसे मैसेज
बॉडी में एंट्री करेंगे चीजों को कंटेंट
लेंथ उसके अकॉर्डिंग अपने आप को चेंज कर
लेगा। अब मैं इसको सेंड करता हूं। इस
रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड करता हूं। लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। अब मैं इस रिक्वेस्ट को
सेंड करता हूं। मैंने इस रिक्वेस्ट को
सेंड किया।
अब देखो इधर रिस्पांस में क्या आएगा?
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ कमिंग इन द रिस्पांस।
अभी आपको रिस्पांस में समझ में आएगा।
रिस्पांस में आ रहा है प्रॉक्सी एरर,
कम्युनिकेशन टाइम आउट, सेंट इज़ इक्वल टू
ट्रू, रिसीव्ड एंप्टी रिस्पांस ट्रू, टाइम
आउट ट्रू। ये सारी चीजें आपके पास आ रही
है। 500 इंटरनल सर्वर। तो, यह जो आपको अभी
प्रॉब्लम आई है, यह जो चीज आई है आपके
पास, यह इसलिए आई है क्योंकि यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ हमारा जीरो है। बिल्कुल
परफेक्ट। एंड कंटेंट भी यहां पर फिलहाल के
लिए हमने कुछ लिखा या कुछ दिया नहीं है।
राइट? अब हम इसको वापस से सेंड करते हैं।
लेट्स सी
सेंड इट अगेन।
अगेन इफ यू सेंड
सी कम्युनिकेशन टाइम आउट आ गया यहां पे।
क्यों? क्योंकि यहां पे ऐसा हो रहा है कि
जब फर्स्ट सर्वर जो हमारा फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
है उसके पास जब रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है तो ये
अगर कंटेंट लेंथ को एक्सेप्ट किया जा रहा
है वहां पे तो कंटेंट लेंथ तो यहां पे
ज़ीरो है।
कंटेंट लेंथ तो ज़ीरो है। अब अगर मैं इस
कंटेंट लेंथ को यहां पे टू कर देता हूं।
एंड अब सेंड करता हूं। लेट्स सी
वी हैव जस्ट डड इट टू। लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग।
अब यहां पर अगेन टाइम आउट आ चुका है। अगेन
फिर से वही सेम टाइम आउट और कंटेंट लेंथ
ऑटोमेटिकली ज़ीरो हो जा रही है। इट मींस
देयर इज़ नो कंटेंट एडेड। यहां पे हमारे
हमने अभी तक कोई कंटेंट ऐड नहीं किया है।
अब एक काम करते हैं। व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू कि यहां पे हम ज़ीरो ही रहने देते हैं।
एंड अकॉर्डिंग टू दिस पर्टिकुलर लैब हम
यहां पे एक कंटेंट को हम पास एक पर्टिकुलर
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग और कंटेंट लेंथ को यहां
पे कस्टमाइज कर देते हैं। कैसे करेंगे? तो
व्हाट? हम यहां पे ज़ीरो देते हैं। वी आर
गिविंग इज़ ज़ीरो। ज़ीरो फॉर टर्मिनेटिंग द
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग। हमने ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को टर्मिनेट कर दिया। आपको पहले
ही मैंने कांसेप्ट में बताया था कि
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग कैसे काम करती है। अब
मैं आपको वहां तक ले चलता हूं। इसलिए
थ्योरी काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होती है। अगर
थ्योरी आप नहीं समझ पाएंगे तो फिर आप
चीजों को नहीं समझ पाएंगे। देखो ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग के बारे में मैंने पहले बताया
था। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हेडर कैन बी यूज़्ड
टू स्पेसिफाई दैट द मैसेज बॉडी यूजेस
चंक्ड इनकोडिंग। हमने कहा था। दिस मींस
दैट द मैसेज बॉडी कंटेन वन और मोर चंक्स
ऑफ़ डेटा। एक या ज्यादा एक से ज्यादा चंक
ऑफ़ डेटा कंटेन करेंगे। ईच चंक कंसिस्ट ऑफ
द चंक साइज इन बाइट्स। तो ये बाइट्स में
होते हैं। जैसे B = बाइट। तो B इक्वल टू
होता है डेसिमल में 11। तो ये B बाइट है
फॉललोड बाय अ न्यू लाइन। उसके बाद एक न्यू
लाइन होती है। फॉललोड बाय द चंक कंटेंट।
उसके बाद जो भी कंटेंट आपका होता है, द
मैसेज इज़ टर्मिनेटेड विद अ चंक साइज़ ऑफ़
ज़ीरो। और उसके बाद ज़ीरो से ज़ीरो का चंक
साइज़ देके और उस मैसेज को टर्मिनेट किया
जाता है, हटाया जाता है। तो हम यहां पे इस
रिक्वेस्ट में क्या बोल रहे हैं कि भैया
जब हमारी ये पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट सर्वर के
पास जाए जो कि ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को यहां
पे प्रायरटाइज कर रही है और फ्रंट एंड सर्
मतलब बैक एंड सर्वर और फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
कंटेंट लेंथ को कर रहा है। ठीक है? तो
यहां पे अब यह ज़ीरो हो जाए जब यह बैक एंड
सर्वर पे जाए यानी टर्मिनेट हो जाए। अब जब
यह टर्मिनेट हो जाएगी तो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
के पास फिर क्या रहेगा? तो उसके लिए हम
यहां पे क्या करने वाले हैं? एक न्यू लाइन
देंगे। यहां पे एक और न्यू लाइन देंगे।
एंड वी विल इशू अ जी।
वी विल इशू अ
टर्म जी। यहां पे हमने जी दिया। अब यह जी
देने से पहले सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज एक चीज
समझनी है। जी देने से पहले यहां पर हमने
जी दिया। अब मैं इस कंटेंट लेंथ को चेंज
करूंगा। बट उसके पहले यहां पे सेटिंग्स
में आके अपडेट कंटेंट लेंथ वाली जो ऑप्शन
है इसको हमें हटानी पड़ेगी। क्योंकि इसको
अगर हम नहीं हटाएंगे तो ये अपने अकॉर्डिंग
कंटेंट लेंथ को जो है वो वहां पे कैलकुलेट
कर लेगा। हमें मैन्युअली खुद से कंटेंट
लेंथ डालनी है तो इसको हटा दो। अब जो है
हम यहां पे मैनुअली अपने अकॉर्डिंग कंटेंट
लेंथ को डाल सकते हैं। सो व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू हम यहां कंटेंट लेंथ को यहां
पे फिलहाल के लिए सिक्स कर देते हैं। अब
ये सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ का मतलब क्या है?
देखो ये कैसे काउंट होगा? तो सिक्स ऐसे
काउंट होगा कि जब ये कंटेंट लेंथ फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर के पास जाएगी सिक्स। तो यहां पे
ये 0 1 2 3 4 5 एंड सिक्स ये काउंट हो
जाएगी। अब यहां पे ये कैसे जब आप इसको
कैसे काउंट करेंगे? किस तरीके से काउंट
करेंगे। लेट्स सी उसको काउंट करने से मतलब
काउंट करेंगे उसके पहले हम इसको थोड़ा सा
समझते हैं कि ये किस तरीके से काम कर रहा
है। अब यहां जी जो है जी इसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं यहां पे सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ये न्यू लाइन यहां से हटा देते हैं। न्यू
लाइन को मैं यहां से हटा के एंड जी के बाद
यहां पे न्यू लाइन दे देता हूं। अब देखो
यहां पे 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 छह हमारे पास डेट
आ गई है। अब जब मैं इस सबको सेलेक्ट
करूंगा जी से ओ तक का जो भी डेटा है तो
यहां पे आप देखेंगे कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स आ
रही है। सिक्स आ रही है जो कंटेंट लेंथ
हमने यहां पे मेंशन किया है। तो बिल्कुल
सही है। ये अलाइंड है। एंड यहां पे मैं
सेंड करूंगा इस रिक्वेस्ट को। अब जब मैं
रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड करूंगा तो ये आएगा
इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट। अब ये इनवैलिड क्यों
आया? व्हाई दिस इज़ कमिंग इनवैलिड? इसका एक
रीज़न है। रीज़न क्या है? जब मैंने ये चीज
करा तो यहां पे आप देख रहे होंगे यू यू
मस्ट बी सीइंग हियर कि यहां पे
सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स है तो छह फ्रंट
एंड को तो छह कंटेंट लेंथ मिल गया 1 2 3 4
5 6 ठीक है इट्स डन मिल गई बैक एंड के पास
चंग्ड है और चंग्ड जो है वो चंग्ड जैसे ही
बैक एंड के पास ये सिक्स हो के पूरी की
पूरी सिक्स जा रही है चंग्ड के बाद यह
ज़ीरो यहां पे टर्मिनेट हो जा रही है चंग्ड
के बाद इट इज़ गेटिंग टर्मिनेटेड
मतलब जैसे यह फ्रंट एंड से पास हो रहा है
फ्रंट एंड अब देखो मैं इसको ऐसे
नोटपड में बताना चाहूंगा
हम
अब जब फ्रंट एंड के पास कंटेनेंस सिक्स है
सिंपल सा फंडा है इट इज़ कंटेनेंस सिक्स तो
व्हाट हैज़ हैपन यहां पे
जो आपका ये सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ है। तो ये
कंप्लीट हो जा रही है। तो ये क्या करेगा?
फ्रंट एंड क्या करेगा कि भैया हां ये पूरा
का पूरा रिक्वेस्ट जो है बैक एंड को भेज
देते हैं। सो इट विल सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट टू
द बैक एंड। ये जो पूरा का पूरा आपका
रिक्वेस्ट है वो पूरा का पूरा बैक एंड को
चला जाएगा। अब बैक एंड में यहां पे चंग्ड
के बाद यहां पे सिंपल बैक एंड में क्या हो
रहा है? चंग्ड है यहां पे। एंड चंग्ड के
बाद यहां पे आपको ज़ीरो ये यहां पे रोक दी
जा रही है। इस रिक्वेस्ट को स्टॉप कर दिया
जा रहा है। इट्स बीन स्टॉप्ड। एज़ सिंपल एज़
दैट। यह रिक्वेस्ट बोल रही है कि नहीं
भैया? अब तो हम रुक गए। अब तो आगे कुछ भी
नहीं है। क्योंकि यहां पे हमारे पास क्या
आ चुका है? हमारे पास ज़ीरो है। इट्स
स्टॉप्ड
बट स्टिल
बट स्टिल व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग वो अभी हम
देखेंगे कि हम इसको सिंपल सा इसको बहुत
सिंपल रखने की कोशिश करेंगे कि अब अगर हम
इसको वापस से सेंड करते हैं। लेट्स सपोज़
इसको हम ऐसे सेंड करते हैं। इट विल अगेन
सेंड इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट। इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट आ गई भैया। यहां पे क्लोज हो
गया। दैट्स इट। खत्म। अब यहां पे हम
नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट पे जाके अगर हम इसको
सेंड करते हैं। इसी नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट को
लेट्स सी।
तो ये नॉर्मल ओके आ रहा है। राइट क्लिक
करके इसको भी हम चेंज कर देंगे। चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड इसको हम पोस्ट कर देंगे
क्योंकि बिना पोस्ट के होगा नहीं।
एचटीडीपी टू आ चुकी है। इसको हम एचटीडीपी
वन पे डाउनग्रेड करेंगे। ये भी बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट है। कंटेंट लेंथ ये अपना ऐसे
ही रहने देते हैं। कोई दिक्कत नहीं आई।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। अब यहां पे स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट पे आते हैं। अब यहां पे हमें
समझना है सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी हमें यहां पे
समझना है पूरी की पूरी सिनेरियो को कि
एग्जैक्टली पूरी सिनेरियो हो क्या रही है?
पूरी सिनेरियो में हमारा मेन मोटिव हमारा
क्या रहा है? हमारा मेन मोटिव है कि भैया
यहां पे इस रिक्वेस्ट को दो बार भेजोगे
एंड दो बार भेजोगे तो ये आएगा
अनरकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट। ऐसा इसलिए
क्यों हो रहा है? क्योंकि यहां पे हमने
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंक रखा है। यहां पे
हमने एक जीरो दे रखा है। एक न्यू लाइन
जीरो के बाद वापस से हमने एक न्यू लाइन दे
रखी है। यहां पे जीरो के बाद यहां पे ये
न्यू लाइन है आपकी। एंड देन आपका जो जी है
वो आपने जी यहां पे मेंशन करके रखा हुआ
है। द जी व्हिच वी हैव द
सॉरी
अह
द जी वी हैव मेंशंड। राइट? दिस इज़ द सेम
थिंग। यह सेम चीज यह सिमिलर चीज आपको यहां
पर मिल रही है। अब यहां पर देखो होता क्या
है? एग्जैक्टली जब आपको यहां पे मैं एक
काम करता हूं। व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू
मैं इसको रिमूव कर देता हूं। सॉरी अ स्लैश
अ n कर देते हैं यहां पे।
ओके स्लैश n कर देते हैं यहां पे। अब इसको
हम चेक करते हैं एक बार। बार व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू चेक इट।
एक बार हम चेक करेंगे। चेक कैसे करेंगे वो
हम देख लेते हैं। तो कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स है
यहां पे। सिक्स इज़ परफेक्ट। यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स है। तो यहां पे हम
रिक्वेस्ट डालते हैं यहां पे। तो ये 1 2 3
4 5 एंड ये छह। ये पूरा का पूरा छह जा रहा
है। तो इसको हम यहां पे रिमूव कर देते
हैं। मैं यहां पे इसको सेंड करता हूं।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। अब जब मैंने
सेंड किया जो न्यू लाइन है उसको हटा के।
आई हैव रिमूव्ड द न्यू लाइन एंड सी व्हाट
इज़ हैपनिंग। थोड़ा वेट हुआ। सर्वर ने वेट
किया।
अब रिस्पांस आपको आएगा टाइम आउट का। देखना
मैंने न्यू लाइन हटा दिया।
एंड यहां पे आ रहा है रीड टाइम आउट बैड
रिक्वेस्ट। ये आ रहा है रीड टाइम आउट बैड
रिक्वेस्ट। ऐसा इसलिए हुआ क्योंकि यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ जो है वो छह हमने बताया हुआ
है। तो क्या किया? फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ने
क्या किया? 1 2 3 4 5 एंड छह। ये छह जो
कंटेंट ये जो छह आपके दिख रहे हैं ना छह
बाइट्स इस छह बाइट को सर् यहां पे फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर ने यह तो यहां पे कॉपी पेस्ट
करने पे ये आएगा भी नहीं यहां पे इस तरीके
से क्योंकि वो नॉन प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स
होते हैं तो इट विल नॉट कम हियर बट ये 6
बाइट को कहां भेज दिया गया बैक एंड सर्वर
को और बैक एंड सर्वर के पास जब ये छह बाइट
गए हैं जैसे ही ये छह बाइट गए हैं तो बैक
एंड सर्वर ने क्या किया बैक एंड सर्वर ने
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंग्ड को एग्
एग्जीक्यूट किया। अब चंक्ड को जब
एग्जीक्यूट किया तो इसके पास क्या
रिक्वेस्ट आई है? इसके पास क्या आई है
हमारे पास? सबसे पहले ज़ीरो आई है। ज़ीरो।
इट मींस ज़ीरो। मतलब कोई चंक ऑफ़ डेटा है ही
नहीं। बट अब कोई चंक ऑफ़ डेटा जब नहीं है,
इट डज़ नॉट हैव एनी चंक ऑफ़ डेटा। तो उसके
पास एक G तो बच गया ना जो क्योंकि ये तो
पूरी गई थी ना कंटेंट में। ये तो पूरी गई
थी बैक एंड सर्वर के पास फ्रंट एंड से। तो
G तो बच गया क्योंकि ज़ीरो तक उसने क्या
किया? यहां तक
जो आपकी बैक एंड सर्वर है उसने यहां तक
पांच बाइट ऑफ डेटा जो है ये पूरा का पूरा
छह बाइट ऑफ डेटा उसके पास चली गई है। बट
जैसे ही उसके पास जब बैक एंड सर्वर ने
ट्रांसफर इंकडिंग चंक् को प्रोसेस किया तो
उसको यहां पे ज़ीरो मिला यानी कि एंड कर
दो। यह कम्युनिकेशन यहीं बंद कर दो। और
बंद होने का मतलब है ये जी जो प्रीवियस जो
डेटा गई थी उसका जी तो बच गया ना समझ रहे
हो इस मैटर को इस चीज को समझ रहे हो जो जी
बच गया आपका आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस थिंग
बताइए मुझे
ये जी बच जा रहा है आर आर यू गेटिंग दिस
थिंग
तीन तीन पर है एंड हो गया बाकी तीन रह गया
कौन सा तीन रह गया
तीन के यहां पे सिक्स की बात हो रही है
यहां पे देयर इज़ सिक्स सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ
है ना तो सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ के ही
अकॉर्डिंग बात करेंगे हम यहां पे
ठीक है
हां। तो अब हमारे पास यहां पर यह जी जो है
वह बच चुका है। अब हम एक नया रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेंगे। नाउ वी विल सेंड अ कंप्लीट न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट। हमें यहां पे अब एक न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट भेजनी है। अब ये जो न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट है ना ये इंपॉर्टेंट रोल आपकी
प्ले करेगी। सो दिस इज़ द परफेक्ट द न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट। अब जो न्यू रिक्वेस्ट जानी है
आपकी उसको
जब ये नॉर्मल ये नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट है
आपका। ठीक है? यह जो एक नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट
आपकी यह गई है और यह हमारा स्मगल डाटा चला
गया। तो स्मगल डाटा जब रीटाइम आउट हो गया।
अब नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट को हम यहां से सेंड
करेंगे।
ये ओके आ रहा है। बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है।
इसमें कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। एक बार इसको
सेंड करके जब देखेंगे तो ये कंप्लीटली ओके
आ रही है। तो यहां पे जब यह रीड टाइम आउट
आ रही है आपकी तो अब यहां पे हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? व्हाट वी विल डू कि हमें यहां
पे चाहिए कि यह उस पर्टिकुलर
अ जो आपकी चंक्ड डेटा है जो आपकी बैक एंड
जो आपको मैनेज कर रही है वहां पे जी पोस्ट
मेथड को ये रिकॉग्नाइज़ करे। तो हमने यहां
पे कंटेंट टाइप ये कंटेंट लेंथ छह कर दिया
यहां पे। अब हम यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं?
यहां पे हमने इसको एक न्यू लाइन दे दिया।
न्यू लाइन देने से ये चीज हो गई कि अब जब
ये चंग्ड बैक एंड के पास जाएगी तो व्हाट
विल हैपन? बैक एंड छह को करेगा तो यह छह
कंटेंट लेंथ हो गई। तो यह छह का छह मान लो
कंटेंट लेंथ ने इसको प्रोसेस कर दिया। 1 2
3 4 5 1 6 उसके बाद जो नई एक रिक्वेस्ट
जाएगी वो बिल्कुल एक फ्रेश रिक्वेस्ट
होगी। तो इसको मैं यहां पे सेंड करता हूं।
लेट्स सी इट्स सेइंग इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट।
अभी यहां पे ये इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट आ रहा
है। इट शुड नॉट बी इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट।
यहां पे अभी मैं अगर सेंड करूंगा भी तो आई
डोंट थिंक इट विल वर्क बिकॉज़ इट्स
लेट्स सी
हम इट्स अ नॉर्मल इट्स अ इट्स अ नॉर्मल
इट्स गोइंग कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अब यहां
पे जो जी अब देखो यहां पे एक चीज़ मैं आपको
बताता हूं। यहां पे हमने जो एक एंटर किया
है चंग्ड यहां पे हमने जो दिया हुआ है
सिक्स का जी आर एन का। अब इसका एक सबसे
बड़ा मोटिव इसका एक सबसे बड़ा मोटिव यहां पे
ये है कि हम यहां पे न्यू लाइन पे इसको हम
सेंड कर रहे हैं। जैसे मैंने क्या किया?
मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं? न्यू लाइन पे
यहां पे एक बार सेंड करके वापस से देखते
हैं। या इट्स सेंड इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट। मैं
इसको इसको बस रिमूव कर देता हूं। जस्ट
रिमूविंग द
अ दिस वन एंड लेट्स सेंड इट। राइट? लेट्स
सेंड इट। लेट्स सी। इट्स सेइंग बैड
रिक्वेस्ट। व्हाई?
इट शुड नॉट बी बैड रिक्वेस्ट। इट शुड बी अ
नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट।
यहां पे ये नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट होना चाहिए।
बैड रिक्वेस्ट नहीं होना चाहिए। इसको हम
एक नए एक डिफरेंट पोस्ट में करके हम एक
बार चेक कर लेंगे। वी विल चेक इट वंस। सो
पहले हम इसको चेक कर लेते हैं। तो एक काम
करते हैं। लेट्स डू वन थिंग। लेट्स रिमूव
इट।
हम इसको हटा देते हैं। ओके ओके ओके ओके सो
दैट्स व्हाई इट्स नॉट वर्किंग लाइक दिस।
सो यहां पे एक न्यू लाइन हम न्यू
प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर देते हैं यहां पे।
यहां पे हमें एक और जो है वो अ आपको
एंट्री करनी पड़ेगी यहां पे। बिकॉज़ यहां पे
सिक्स लेंथ का करैक्टर है। तो बेसिकली हम
यहां से शुरू करेंगे। तो तीन चार पांच और
छह ये तीन जो है वो हो जाएंगे। एंड आपके
पास जो है अब जो है ये परफेक्ट आपका ये जो
है ये बनेगा। लेट्स सी अब इस तरह से ये
रिस्पांस आना चाहिए। बिल्कुल। अब आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे 200 ओके रिस्पांस आ चुका
है। एंड इफ यू विल गो टू द नॉर्मल
रिक्वेस्ट एंड इफ यू विल सेंड दिस
रिक्वेस्ट वंस अगेन तो यहां पे आपको आएगा
अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट एंड इट विल
से दैट लॉ लैब हैज़ बीन सॉल्व्ड। अब ये लैब
जो है ये सॉल्व हो चुका है। अब इसका रीज़न
क्या है? आप आपको शायद अब समझ में आया
होगा क्योंकि यहां पे हमने एक गड़बड़ी
क्या की थी? हम यहां पे न्यू लाइन नहीं दे
रहे थे। बिकॉज़ ये ये जो हमने ऑफ किया तो
हमें यहां पे दिखा कि एग्जैक्टली यहां पे
एक आपको न्यू लाइन चाहिए चाहिए। इसका रीज़न
क्या है? मैं आपको समझाता हूं इसका। इसका
मतलब समझाता हूं कि हुआ क्या एग्जैक्टली
है। यहां पे हमने कंटेंट लेंथ तो छह दिया
और यह clt वलेबिलिटी है। तो clt में
कंटेंट लेंथ को फ्रंट एंड सर्वर प्रेफर
करता है। तो जब ये रिक्वेस्ट पहली
रिक्वेस्ट नॉर्मल जो रिक्वेस्ट है पहली
रिक्वेस्ट जब जाएगी जो कि इसको हम स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट बोल रहे हैं। तो जब ये फ्रंट
एंड सर्वर के पास जाएगी तो फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर जो है वो सिक्स को देखेगा। सिक्स
काउंट होगी कहां से? यहां से। तो यह जो
जीरो है ना जीरो आपकी जीरो यहां से आपकी
सिक्स काउंट हो जाएगी। तो व्हाट विल हैपन?
देखो यहां पे 1 2 3 4 5 6 G तक ये सिक्स
काउंट होगी। तो जी तक उसने डेटा भेज दिया।
लेकिन उसके साथ-साथ जी के साथ-साथ यह पूरी
डाटा क्योंकि सिक्स यहां तक काउंट हुई है
तो यह पूरी डाटा जो है ना वो बैक एंड
सर्वर के पास चली गई है। पूरी डाटा भी बैक
एंड सर्वर के पास चली गई है। अब बैक एंड
सर्वर के पास जब जाएगी ये रिक्वेस्ट सेम
रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी तो बैक एंड सर् बैक एंड
सर्वर जो है वो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को यहां
पे प्रेफर करेगा चंग्ड में। चंग्ड में
उसको यहां पे ज़ीरो दिखेगी। तो यहीं पे ये
खत्म हो जाएगी लाइन तीन यहां पे खत्म हो
गई। तीन करके ओवर। अब उसके पास अब बच गई
चंक के पास क्या बच गई? 1 2 3 4 5 बाइट।
फाइव बाइट्स बच गई। लेकिन अब फाइव बाइट्स
तो बच गई है हमारे पास।
फ्रंट एंड बैक एंड जो आपका बैक एंड है
यहां पे। इसमें ये क्या करेगा? जो चंग्ड
है जो पहले का एक जी बचा हुआ था। क्योंकि
द व्हाट विल हैपन? फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ने
क्या किया था? 1 2 3 4 5
यहां पे 1 2 3 4 5 एंड ये छह छह को
प्रोसेस करके पूरा का पूरा छह भेज दिया।
दैट्स इट छह वहां पे प्रोसेस हो गई है।
हमारा फ्रंट एंड सर्वर का काम कंप्लीट हो
गया। लेकिन जो बैक एंड सर्वर है वो चंग्ड
है। वो तो यहीं पे रुक जा रही है। ये यहीं
पे खत्म हो गई ना? तो उसके बाद ये जो
फालतू के पड़े हुए हैं डेटा ये जो डेटा
पड़े हुए हैं इनका क्या मतलब है? यह एक नए
रिक्वेस्ट में अपेंड हो जाएंगे। नए
रिक्वेस्ट में डाटा पढ़ने के लिए कौन सी
अपेंड बची हुई है? यह जी पटी हुई है। जी द
जी हैज़ बीन लेफ्ट। एक जी बची हुई है आपके
पास। अब ये जी बची हुई है। जब हम नॉर्मल
रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करेंगे तो ये इसमें अपेंड
हो जाता है। इस रिक्वेस्ट में ये जो पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है इसमें ये अपेंड हो
जाएगा। अब ये कैसे आपको मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं। जैसे मैं अगर इस पूरे बाकी के
हेडर्स फालतू हेडर्स को यहां से हटा दूं।
लेट्स रिमूव दिस हेडर्स। एंड यहां पे ये
जी पोस्ट है ना जी पोस्ट हो जा रही है। अब
मैं यहां पे अगर लेट्स सपोज़
मैं यहां पे जी के जगह पे लेट्स सपोज यहां
पे मैं अगर जी के जगह पे जी डी कर दूं।
अगर जी डी कर देता हूं। लेट्स सपोज इट्स
जी डी। ठीक है? और मैं अगर अब सेंड करूंगा
तो क्या होगा? देखो
देखो क्या होगा? ये 200 हो के आ रहा है।
नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट को मैं यहां पे सेंड
करूंगा।
अब यहां पर रिस्पांस आएगा कि अगेन कि
अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट। अब यहां पे
मैंने जीडी किया लेकिन मेथड क्योंकि
रिप्लाई में हमें हमें क्या मिल रहा है
यहां पे जो हमें नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट किया जी
पोस्ट ही मिल रहा है। जीडी पोस्ट नहीं मिल
रहा है। इसका रीज़न सबसे बड़ा रीज़न ये है कि
हम यहां पे सिर्फ और सिर्फ जो हमारा डाटा
जा रहा है बैक एंड के पास वो तो वही जा
रही है ना। जी उसके बाद तो कुछ भी नहीं।
तो उसके बाद तो कुछ भी जा रही है वो अपेंड
होगी। तो पहले ही जब जी अपेंड हो जा रही
है नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट में तो जी पोस्ट बन
जा रही है। एंड जब आपका ये पर्टिकुलर अ
सर्वर बैक एंड सर्वर देख रहा है ना जी
पोस्ट तो उसको लग रहा है ये जी पोस्ट क्या
है? व्हाट इज दिस जी पोस्ट? उसको कोई मतलब
ही नहीं है। जी पोस्ट क्या है? डजंट मैटर।
जी पोस्ट देख के ही बोल रहा है कि भैया ये
तो इनवैलिड मेथड है। यहां पे आ रहा है
अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट। ये बोल रहा
है मैं तो इस मेथड को जानता ही नहीं हूं।
इसके बाद का तो बात अलग है। इसके बाद तो
दूसरी कहानी है। बट मैं तो इस मेथड को
जानता ही नहीं हूं। दैट्स इट। तो उसको समझ
में नहीं आता है और वो डाल देता है
अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड जी पोस्ट और यहां पे
आपकी जो है ये चीज कंप्लीट हो जाती है।
यही सेम चीज जैसे कि अगर ये लैब तो सॉल्व
हो गई है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। अब मुझे एक
चीज़ बताइए आप लोग सिंपल सा फंडा कि ये
क्या हो गया? ओबीएस डिस्कनेक्ट क्यों हो
गई यार? हद है यार।
[संगीत]
ओके वापस से कनेक्ट हो गई। आई थिंक ओबीएस
वाज़ डिस्कनेक्टेड सॉरी फॉर दैट। हां
हां हां तो जी के जगह अभी अभी ही इज़ सेइंग
कि जी के जगह सर पी क्या डाल के देखिए
क्या बोला आपने? जी के जगह पे पी डाल के
देखिए। ठीक है? इन्होंने बोला कि सर जी की
जगह पी डाल के देखिए। हां। तो पी डाल दो।
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। पी डाल दो। यहां पे
सेंड कर दो। यू विल गेट द ओके। नॉर्मल
रिक्वेस्ट को यहां पे सेंड कर दो।
यू विल गेट पी पोस्ट क्योंकि बेसिकली इनको
मतलब पता नहीं है ना कि यह क्या है तो कुछ
भी डाल सकते हो यहां पे पी के जगह पे हां
अब अगर यहां पे तुमने यहां पे इसके जगह पे
मान लो पी के जगह पे भी डिफ्रॉनिक्स डाल
दिया लेट्स सपोज वी एडेड द डिफ्रॉनिक्स
हमने डिफ्रॉनिक्स डाल दिया अब मैं इसको
यहां पे सेंड करूंगा देखो क्या होगा यहां
पे ओके आया नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे सेंड
किया ये देखो रिस्पांस में यहां पे क्या आ
रही है अन रिकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड डी पोस्ट
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट नहीं आया
यहां पे अब देखो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स
पोस्ट नहीं आया मैंने यहां पे क्या लिखा
है डिफ्रॉनिक्स
बट यहां पे क्या आया डी पोस्ट इट्स नॉट
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट ऐसा क्यों हुआ समझ में
आपको आ रहा है ऐसा क्यों हुआ क्योंकि यह
थोड़ी समझने वाली चीज है थोड़ी समझिए इसको
द रीज़न इज़ कि यहां पे मैंने क्या किया था।
सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ लिया है यहां पे। यहां
पे द कंटेंट लेंथ इज़ सिक्स। एज़ सिंपल ऐज़
दैट। तो सिक्स जब पहली बार सर्वर के पास
जा रही है फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के पास तो छह
कंटेंट लेंथ होगी यहां पे। 1 2 3 4 5 एंड
छह। ये डी तक ही तो जा रही है कंटेंट
लेंथ। उसके बाद क्या लिखा है? उससे क्या
मतलब है? वो डी तक ही तो भेज रहा है सर्वर
को। सर्वर के पास एक डी जो है ना डी वो
पड़ी हुई है। क्यों? क्योंकि सर्वर जीरो तक
ही रुक जा रही है। सर्वर जीरो पे खत्म हो
जा रही है। यहां पे सर्वर जीरो पे एंड हो
जा रही है। क्योंकि सर्वर चंग्ड इनकोडिंग
को प्रेफर कर रही है। चंग्ड यहां पे ज़ीरो
हो जा रहा है। अब ज़ीरो के बाद क्या है?
उसकी कोई वैल्यू नहीं है। चंग्ड सर्वर बैक
एंड सर्वर के लिए। बैक एंड सर्वर डज़ नॉट
हैव एनी काइंड ऑफ़ वैल्यू फॉर द थिंग्स दैट
इज़ हैपनिंग आफ्टर ज़ीरो।
अब जब नई रिक्वेस्ट आएगी तो उसके लिए एक
नया रिक्वेस्ट होगा सब कुछ। तो उस नए
रिक्वेस्ट में कुछ भी होगा व्हाटएवर उसमें
से वह जो डी है ना डी जो बच गई है डी तो
बची हुई है ना सर्वर के पास उसको अपेंड कर
देगा अब नई रिक्वेस्ट कौन सी आई है नई
रिक्वेस्ट आपकी ये पोस्ट आई है पोस्ट और
कुछ भी नहीं है ये पोस्ट वाली है न्यू
न्यू रिक्वेस्ट दिस इज़ द न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
नथिंग एल्स
दिस थिंग हैज़ हैपेंड यह है मेन चीज़ फंडा
समझ में आ रहा है
हां इफ
इफ वी यूज़ कंटेंट लेंथ सेवन सो आवर
रिक्वेस्ट विल बी डी डी ई पोस्ट हां देखो
ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे एक चीज़ और
इन्होंने क्वेश्चन करा है। अब मैं यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ अगर सेवन कर दूं इफ वी आर
डूइंग कंटेंट लेंथ सेवन और मैं ये सब कुछ
सेम रहने देता हूं। एवरीथिंग एल्स इज़
बिल्कुल डिट्टो सेम। अब मैं इसको सेंड
करता हूं।
लेट्स सी मैंने सेंड किया। रिस्पांस 200
ओके आया। अब मैं नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट को यहां
पर सेंड करता हूं। नाउ यू विल गेट द
रिस्पांस डीई पोस्ट। बिल्कुल सही। आयुष
पटेल। आयुष पटेल का मुझे लगता है कांसेप्ट
क्लियर है। उसको पूरा क्लियर समझ में आ
रहा है। तो ये क्यों हुआ? क्योंकि हमने
कंटेंट लेंथ को सेवन कर दिया। सो नाउ से
जब हो गया इसका मतलब यह है कि यह 1 2 3 4
5 एंड ये छ 7 डी तक सेवन होगी। होगी देखो
ना यहां पे सेवन सिलेक्शन सेवन आई देखो ना
यहां पे राइट में टॉप राइट में यहां पे
देखोगे हियर
यहां पे देखो
ये रही सेवन आ रही है कैरेक्टर अकाउंट तो
सेवन तक भेज रहा है ये सर्वर को
और सर्वर के पास जब ये रिक्वेस्ट जा रही
है बेसिकली तो कैसे खत्म हो जा रही है
ज़ीरो पे ही खत्म हो जा रही है
ज़ीरो पे खत्म हो जा रही है ज़ीरो के बाद
कोई डेटा का कुछ मतलब ही नहीं है तो जब
ज़ीरो के बाद खत्म हो जा रही है भैया तो
हमारे पास ये पूरी रिक्वेस्ट गई थी ना वी
हैव सेंड ऑल द रिक्वेस्ट जो भी ये सात जो
है ना यहां तक गई थी ना डीई तक तो डीई तो
पड़ी है सर्वर के पास सर्वर के पास अभी भी
डीई है यानी जब क्लाइंट ने भेजा तो भैया
ये पूरी गई है देखो मैं अब
0 डीई यह गई है। यह तब हुआ है
जब
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ने भेजा डेटा। उसने भेजा
जीरो डीई दोनों
ये डाटा भेज दी।
अब जब बैक एंड सर्वर प्रोसेस करेगा
तो बैक एंड जो है ज़ीरो पे रुक जाएगी। बैक
एंड ज़ीरो पे क्यों रुक जाएगी? क्योंकि
उसको ज़ीरो मिल गया ना। ट्रांस ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग चंग्ड पे काम कर रहा है और
ट्रांसफरिंग चंग्ड अगर ज़ीरो आप दे दोगे तो
वहीं पे कनेक्शन को टर्मिनेट कर देना है।
तो अब बैकेंड के पास क्या बचा? डीई बचा।
अब नेक्स्ट एक रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है जो कि
स्टार्ट हो रही है पोस्ट से। तो बैक एंड
ने क्या किया? डीई साथ में जोड़ दिया। डीई
पोस्ट बन गई है। पोस्ट ना रह के सिर्फ डीई
पोस्ट बन गई। अब बैक एंड बोल रहा है कि
भैया डीई पोस्ट क्या होता है? डीई पोस्ट
कौन सा मेथड है?
हां राइट।
NR भी जा रही है। बिल्कुल ये जो ज़ीरो है
ये आपकी जो ज़ीरो जा रही है इसके साथ-साथ
स्लश R N भी जा रही है। फिर नीचे स्लश R N
भी जा रही है। देन आपका DE जो है वो आपका
DE ये जा रहा है। टोटल कितने जा रहे हैं?
1 तीन ये दो ये पांच और दो सात क्योंकि
कंटेन लेंथ सात है तो सात जा रहे हैं।
दैट्स इट। तो अब ये जा तो रहे हैं सात।
क्योंकि अब जब बैक एंड सर्वर के पास
क्योंकि यह ट्रांसफर
कुछ इस तरीके से दिखेगी। मैं आपको दिखाने
की कोशिश करता हूं। ठीक है? बैक एंड सर्वर
के पास देखो यहां पे बैक एंड सर्वर के पास
ये ऐसी रहेगी ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग एंड यहां पे रहेगा चंग्ड। अब
चंग्ड में क्या होगा? यहां पे ये छोड़ो।
यहां पे इसको तो पहले ही ज़ीरो मिल रही है
ना क्योंकि ज़ीरो और DE है तो यहां पे एक
ज़ीरो मिल रही है सॉरी इसको ज़ीरो मिल रहा
है और इसको DE मिल रहा है DE तो चंग
इनकोडिंग को ये प्रोसेस करेगा जब बैक एंड
तो ये ज़ीरो देख के ही यहीं पे खत्म कर
देगा अपनी टर्मिन अपनी कनेक्शन यहीं पे
तोड़ देगा बैक एंड सर्वर तो बैक एंड के पास
बस बच गई डी ये डी क्या हो गया स्मगल डाटा
स्मगल डाटा ये डी बच गई
अब यही डी जब नेक्स्ट न्यू रिक्वेस्ट आएगी
न्यू रिक्वेस्ट जो कि क्या आ रही है न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट देखो जो एक नॉर्मल रिक्वेस्ट
हमने क्या भेजा न्यू रिक्वेस्ट में यह
भेजा न्यू रिक्वेस्ट में क्या आ रही है
अरे भैया
कॉपी तो हो जा [हंसी]
यहां से कॉपी नॉर्मल सा कॉपी कर ले
हां अब ये जो न्यू रिक्वेस्ट है
डीई बची हुई है। न्यू रिक्वेस्ट इस तरीके
से ये जा रही है। तो इसी न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
में ये डीई तो अपेंड होगा क्योंकि उसके
पास डीई पहले से है। DE डाल दी पहले। DE
पोस्ट हो गई।
यस 13 से हम पूरा यह समझ में आ रहा है
आपको? अब तो समझ में आया होगा यार। अब तो
इतना क्लेरिटी से बताया मैंने। अब तो समझ
में आया होगा। बताओ लेट मी नो। इफ यू आर
गेटिंग इट।
इफ यू आर गेटिंग इट। जस्ट लेट मी नो।
लेट मी नो गाइस।
अब समझ में आ गया? सब कुछ? सब कुछ समझ में
आया कि नहीं आया?
यह पूरा मेथड है। यह पूरा फंडा है यार।
हां।
ठीक है? ये सेम कांसेप्ट है जो मैंने आपको
cl.t वलेबिलिटी के टाइम पे आपको पहले भी
बताया था। थ्योरी में जो मैंने बताया था
ना आपको cl.t देखो।
यह cl मैंने आपको सेम बताया था कि यह
कंटेंट लेंथ 13 है तो यह 13 तक जाएगी उसके
बाद नहीं जाएगी। ये सारी चीजें आपको बताई
हुई थी। तो ये सिमिलर कांसेप्ट यहां पे
फॉलो हो रही है। बस दैट्स इट। यही तो है
डी पोस्ट हो गया। अब इसी को अगर आप टेस्ट
आउट करना चाहते हो। लेट्स सपोज इफ यू वांट
टू टेस्ट समथिंग कि ये एग्जैक्टली ये क्या
काम कैसे कर रहा है। अगर आप टेस्ट करना
चाहते हो तो मैं क्या करता हूं? मैं इस
कंप्लीटली इस सबको हटा देता हूं। इन सबको
मैंने यहां पर
चंग्ड यह सब मैंने रिमूव कर दिया। मैं
यहां पर कंटेंट लेंथ जो है वह भी यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए कंटेंट लेंथ मैं इसको ज़ीरो
समझ रहा हूं। और मैं इसको कंटेंट अपडेट
लेंथ को इनेबल कर दे रहा हूं ताकि अपने
अकॉर्डिंग कंटेंट लेंथ को यहां पे हमें
प्रोवाइड कर दे। अब मैं यहां पे क्या कर
रहा हूं? एक न्यू लाइन दे रहा हूं। ठीक
है? एक सिंपल सा न्यू लाइन। और मैं यहां
पे
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंक्ड ज़ीरो कर दे रहा
हूं। लेट्स सपोज ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग इन
चंक्ड = 0 और मैं यहां पे कुछ भी अभी
फिलहाल नहीं दे रहा। मैं यहां पे एक और
एंटर कर दे रहा हूं न्यू लाइन करके एंड
यहां पे एक डेटा डाल दे रहा हूं
डिफ्रॉनिक्स।
यहां मैंने एक डेटा डाल दी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स।
अब मैं जब इस रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड करूंगा।
लेट्स सी आई एम सेंडिंग दिस रिक्वेस्ट।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। यहां पे क्या
आ रहा है? 40 गेटवे टाइम आउट। गेटवे टाइम
आउट। कुछ इस तरीके से कनेक्टिंग टू ऐसा
कुछ करके ये गेटवे टाइम आउट आ गया। इसलिए
क्योंकि ये अभी रीलोड करेंगे तो इसमें इशू
आएगा। देखो ये एरर आ गई। इस वजह से ये
गेटवे टाइम आउट हो गई। ये रिक्वेस्ट ही
मतलब खत्म हो गई है। ठीक है?
हां हां करेक्ट। करेक्ट। जहां से हमारा
कंटेंट स्टार्ट होता है। बिल्कुल सही बात
है। अब यह रिक्वेस्ट नॉर्मल यह रिक्वेस्ट
हट गई है। तो इस रिक्वेस्ट को मैं यहां से
हटा देता हूं।
लेट्स रिमूव दिस पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट।
लेट्स गो टू द प्रॉक्सी। प्रॉक्सी में
सारे जो है क्लियर कर देते हैं। क्लियर
हिस्ट्री एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर। यहां पर
चलते हैं। एंड यहां पे इसको वापस से रीलोड
कर लेते हैं। जैसे ही रीलोड करेंगे वी विल
सी इट विल बी गेटिंग पॉपुलेटेड हियर। यहां
पे आ गया है। वापस से हम इसको फिर से
करेंगे। मतलब उसको भेज देंगे। अभी फिर से
यह नहीं आया। फिर से मैं रीलोड फिर से
रीलोड करता हूं। यह अगेन सेम चीज नाटक कर
रहा है। तो एक बार यहां से लैब ओपन कर
लेते हैं। फिर से एक्सेस द लैब। ओके।
लेट्स सी।
ओके ये आ गई लेटेस्ट वाली
ये ओपन हो गई। ये आ गई हमारे पास। आई एम
गुड। आई एम गुड। आई एम गुड। इसको वापस से
सेंड टू रिपीटर भेजते हैं। रिपीटर को हमने
भेज दिया। रिपीटर पे आ गए यहां पे। ठीक
है? अब यहां पे हमने जो नॉर्मल सा पहले
काम था वो पहले कर लेते हैं। जो नॉर्मल जो
भी काम है आपका वो पहले कर लेते हैं। ठीक
है? लेट्स सी।
सो सबसे पहले तो एचटीटीपी एट्रिब्यूट्स
चेक करेंगे। वर्जन वन पे होना चाहिए। वन
पे ऑलरेडी है। तो इतना रहने देते हैं।
दूसरा यहां पे सबसे पहली चीज़ इसको राइट
क्लिक करेंगे एंड चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड
पोस्ट कर देंगे। फालतू के जितने भी यहां
पे हेडर्स हैं उनको हम यहां से रिमूव कर
देंगे। दे एग्जैक्टली इज़ नॉट रिक्वायर्ड।
अब यहां पे सारा गेम यहां पर है। अब मैं
यहां पर कंटेंट लेंथ को जीरो ही रहने देता
हूं। फिलहाल के लिए कोई चेंजज़ नहीं, कुछ
भी नहीं। प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स को ऑन कर
लेंगे यहां पे। और यहां पे जो अपडेट
कंटेंट लेंथ है, इसको हम इनेबल करके रखते
हैं ताकि ये कंटेंट लेंथ अपने अकॉर्डिंग
कर ले। ठीक है? अब मैं यहां पे क्या करता
हूं?
यहां पे मैंने एक न्यू लाइन दिया। एंड
यहां पे मैं कुछ टाइप कर देता हूं। लेट्स
सपोज मैंने टाइप किया डिफ़्रॉनिक्स।
मैंने डिफ़्रॉनिक्स टाइप किया। दैट्स इट।
अब देखना क्या होगा। अब मैं इस रिक्वेस्ट
को सेंड करता हूं। ठीक है? मैंने सेंड
किया। अब इसने ऑटोमेटिकली कंटेंट लेंथ
कितना बना दिया? इट्स एट। एट बना दिया
इसने। कैसे? ये डिफ्रॉनिक्स टोटल इज़ एट।
तो इसने एट बना दिया। हो गया। अब इसने
स्लश RN ये जो है इसको कंसीडर नहीं किया
क्योंकि ये कंटेंट लेंथ के बाद का एक न्यू
लाइन है जिसको कि कंसीडर करने की कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। इसके बाद अगर कुछ
होती है। जैसे कि अगर मैं यहां पे अगर मैं
एंटर मारता हूं। R n ऐसे करके मैं एंटर
मार दिया। अब मैं इसको रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड
करूंगा। तो अभी रिस्पांस आएगा आपको देखना।
अब कंटेंट लेंथ देखो कितना हो गया। अब
कंटेंट लेंथ समझ में आ गया कितना हो गया।
नाउ यू गॉट कंटेंट लेंथ। कितना कंटेंट
लेंथ हुआ? अभी समझ में आ गया।
इसने ऑटोमेटिकली 10 कर दिया इसको। क्यों?
क्योंकि अब ये डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के साथ-साथ
स्लैश RN को भी कंसीडर कर रहा है। एक न्यू
लाइन पे जस्ट वन न्यू लाइन। अगेन अगर मैं
एक और न्यू लाइन मार देता हूं तो अब
कंटेंट लेंथ कितना हो जाएगा? 12 होना
चाहिए। लेट्स सी। सो कंटेंट लेंथ इज 12।
तो कंटेंट लेंथ 12 हो गया। ठीक है? एक और
मार देता हूं। तो अब वो 14 होना चाहिए। तो
ये 14 हो गया। तो आर यू गेटिंग
अंडरस्टैंडिंग द लॉजिक्स? ये पूरा लॉजिक
है। अब मैं इसको यहां से रिमूव करता हूं।
हट जाता हूं। हटा देता हूं। अब मेरे पास
यहां पे ये सारी चीजें सेट है। कंटेंट
लेंथ मैंने 14 करके रखा हुआ है। ठीक है?
इट्स 14।
एंड यहां पे कंटेंट जो है ये टोटल हमने
कितना दे रखा है? 10 दे रखा है। 10 तो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू? आई एम गोइंग टू
इशू अ कमांड ट्रांस अ हेडर ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग। तो मैं क्या करता हूं?
ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग एंड मैं यहां पे कॉलन दे देता
हूं। तो ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को चंग्ड कर
देता हूं। एंड r n बस ये मैंने लिख दिया।
अब यहां पे जब मैंने ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
चंग्ड दिया है तो व्हाट आई विल आई विल डू
व्हाट आई विल डू हियर कि मैं 14 कैरेक्टर
ये जो 14 कैरेक्टर का कंटेंट लेंथ अभी
हमने यहां पे मेंशन किया है। क्योंकि ये
जो है टोटल और जबकि ये जो है टोटल 10
कैरेक्टर का है। तो व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू
डू मैं यहां पे अपडेट कंटेंट लेंथ वाला
ऑटोमेशन वाले को हटा देता हूं। मैं खुद से
यहां पे मेंशन करूंगा। एंड एंड यहां पे
मेरा कंटेंट लेंथ दिख रहा है क्या? 10। इट
इज़ शोइंग 10। तो मैं यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ
को 10 कर देता हूं। ताकि हमारा फ्रंट एंड
का सेटिस्फाई हो जाए सब कुछ। तो मैंने 10
किया। अब ये 10 कंटेंट लेंथ भी 10 है। तो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू? आई एम गोइंग टू
सेंड इट। अब मैं सेंड जब करूंगा तो ये आ
रहा है इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट। इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट क्यों आ रही है? व्हाई इट इज़
कमिंग इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट? बिकॉज़
फ्रंट एंड ने तो इसको
प्रोसेस कर दिया। फ्रंट एंड ने तो इसको
प्रोसेस कर दिया। 10 का 10 10 कंटेंट लेंथ
है। 10 आपको इसको कंटेंट लेंथ मिल भी गया।
बट क्योंकि बैक एंड अब इसको ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को प्रोसेस कर रहा है। इससे ही
चेक हो रहा है यहां पे। दिस इज़ गेटिंग
चेक्ड। इस वजह से ये इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है। बस अगर मैं इस ट्रांसफर कोडिंग
चंक्ड को हटा दूं ना यहां पे कंट्रोल x
करके हटा दूं तो ये सेंड करूंगा ना ये
वैलिड रिक्वेस्ट होगी। देखो 200 ओके
देखो 200 ओके हो रहा है वैलिड रिक्वेस्ट
हो रही है। इसका मतलब है कि ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग इज़ यूज्ड बाय बैक एंड समझ में
आया? किसी ने पूछा था अह किसने पूछा था कि
कैसे
हम समझेंगे कि बैक एंड फ्रंट एंड क्या यूज़
करा है एंड बैक एंड क्या यूज़ कर रहा है?
तो आई थिंक आपका आंसर यहां पे मिल मिल
चुका होगा कि ये तरीका है पता लगाने का।
तो हमने एक कंटेंट लेंथ किया तो हमें ओके
200 ओके आ रहा है। यानी कि द रिक्वेस्ट इज़
परफेक्ट। द रिक्वेस्ट। हां। तो अभी आपको
शिवम समझ में आ चुका होगा शायद कि यहां पर
फ्रंट एंड जो है आपका
कंटेंट लेंथ यूज़ कर रहा है। इसीलिए जब मैं
बैक एंड पर आ रहा हूं,
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग जब मैं लगा दे रहा हूं,
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग?
इट इज़ सेइंग इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट।
समझ में आ रहा है? क्योंकि ये ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग को प्रोसेस कर रहा है। और
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग में चंग्ड तो आ चुका
है। चंक्ड इज़ आ चुका है। ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग चंक्ड हमने लिखा। लेकिन इसकी कुछ
तो वैल्यू डिफाइन करो। इसका तो बताओ तो
सही। कितने बाइट का चंक है? कब खत्म होगा?
यह भी तो बताओ। यह भी तो बताने वाली चीज
है। कितने बाइट का है। तो अब हमें यहां पे
जब चंग्ड इनकोडिंग को हम बताएंगे इफ वी
विल शो द चंग्ड इनकोडिंग तो इसका एक
फॉर्मेट होता है। जो फॉर्मेट मैंने आपको
ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ था कि चंग्ड इनकोडिंग जो
होती है जो आपकी ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग की जो
होती है उसका एक फॉर्मेट होता है। अब यहां
पे मैं उस फॉर्मेट को यहां पे डालूं डालने
डालने की कोशिश करूंगा। किस तरीके से मैं
यहां पर एक काम करता हूं। आई एम गोइंग टू
गिव इट अ जीरो।
अब मैं यहां पे जीरो दे देता हूं कि भैया
तुम अब जीरो।
ठीक है? सो अब सेंड करते हैं इस रिक्वेस्ट
को। तो अब जब इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम सेंड
करेंगे, तो ये अगेन इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है। इसका रीज़ है। द रीज़न इज़ कि यहां
पे यह जो चीज है, यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ
हमारी चेंज हो चुकी है। इस जीरो की वजह
से। दैट्स व्हाई इट सेइंग इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट।
सो अब व्हाट वी विल डू कि हम इसको चेक
करेंगे। कैसे चेक चेक करेंगे हम? किस
तरीके से चेक करेंगे? तो यहां पे अब हमारा
जो कंटेंट लेंथ है
वो है 13। वी हैव 13 कंटेंट लेंथ। तो हम
यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ को एक बार 13 कर देते
हैं। चंग यहां पे ज़ीरो रहने देते हैं और
एक बार सेंड करते हैं। लेट्स सी इट्स
कॉल्ड बैड रिक्वेस्ट इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट।
यहां पे अब ये इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट आ रहा
है। इसका रीज़न ये है कि चंग्ड को यहां पे
ज़ीरो तो मिल चुका। चंग्ड गॉट इज़ ज़ीरो। अब
उसके बाद ये फालतू के डेटा चले गए।
बट यहां पे स्टिल इट्स सेइंग कि फ्रंट एंड
को 13 कररेक्टर चाहिए।
सो दिस इज़ द मेन इशू। दिस इज़ द मेन फंडा।
कि यहां पर यह गड़बड़ हो रही है। अब मैं
यहां पर अगर मैं पहले जैसे 10 ही करके
रखूं और मैं यहां पर यह वाली चीज हटा दूं।
ये जीरो वाली चीज हटा दूं और मैं इसको
सेंड करूं तो देखो नॉर्मल एज नॉर्मल यहां
पे अगेन यहां पे कुछ गड़बड़ हो गई है।
ओके? ट्रांसफर कोडिंग हमने लगा दिया है।
यहां पे ये 10 का 10 है। ठीक है? कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। अब यहां पे ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग चंक लिख दिया है। तो इसको भी आपको
फुलफिल करना पड़ेगा। यू हैव टू फुलफिल दिस
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग चंग्ड वाली जो डेटा है।
अब इस डेटा को मैं मान लो कुछ भी लिख सकता
हूं। व्हाटएवर आई कैन आई वांट आई कैन राइट
दिस डेटा। अब इस डेटा में मैं मान लूं कि
अ आई वांट टू ऐड समथिंग तो क्या ऐड करें?
अ व्हाट शुड वी ऐड?
तो
चलो इसमें वन डाइट वन ऐड कर देते हैं। वन
ऐड कर देते हैं। जस्ट वन एंड लेट्स सेंड
इट। अगेन इट विल से इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट
क्योंकि यह वैलिड है नहीं क्योंकि यह
ट्रांस कोड चंक् आके वन यहां पर डाटा वन
फच कर रहा है। इसको वन बाइट डेटा चाहिए।
बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। इट्स रिक्वायर्स वन
बाइट डेटा।
एंड वन बाइट डेटा के बाद यहां पे अगर हमने
एंटर देके एंड हियर अगर हमने यहां पे
लेट्स सपोज एक एक बाइट का डेटा यहां पे
हमने दे भी दिया। मान लो हमने कोई एक डेटा
दे दी। जैसे कि हमने दे दी d या हमने दे
दिया x
x दे दिया एक बाइट का डेटा अब हम इसको
सेंड करते हैं लेट्स सी क्या होता है
से अगेन वेट करेगा ये अब ये टाइम लगा रहा
है कनेक्शन टाइम आउट
देखो कम्युनिकेशन टाइम आउट अब यहां पे
क्या ऑप्शन आपको आ रहा है कम्युनिकेशन
टाइम आउट कम्युनिकेशन टाइम आउट हो गया
क्यों हो अब इसका रीज़न यह है। द रीज़न इज़ द
फर्स्ट द मेन रीज़न इज़ कि जैसे ही फ्रंट
एंड के पास गया फ्रंट एंड को कंटेंट लेंथ
10 दिख रहा है। तो कंटेंट लेंथ 10 उसने
क्या किया? उसने देखा 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 यहां तक उसने भेज दिया।
यहां तक उसने बैक एंड को भेज दिया पूरा का
पूरा। अब जब बैक एंड के पास ये चीज गई है
तो बैक एंड ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग चंग्ड को
देख रहा है और चंग्ड जो है वो यहां पे
सिंपल सा फंडा क्या दिखा रहा है कि ये एक
हेक्साडेेसिमल नंबर वन है वन के बाद एक
बाइट की डेटा इसको चाहिए एक बाइट की इसका
मतलब है वन बाइट डेटा नीडेड तो वन बाइट
डाटा इसको एक
इनवैलिड यहां पे एक डाटा यहां पे इसको मिल
रही 1 बाइट डाटा
बस एक बाइट का डाटा मिल गया। अब क्योंकि
यह इसके पास फालतू के डेटा पड़े हुए हैं।
तो ये अब सोच रहा है कि भैया और भी कुछ
डाटा है क्या?
वेट कर रहा है और भी कुछ डाटा है क्या?
क्योंकि हमने इसको टर्मिनेट नहीं किया है।
हमने इसको वन बाय डाटा दे दी। चंक्ड
इनकोडिंग को पहला क्योंकि चंक्ड इनकोडिंग
का ट्रांस कोडिंग का फॉर्मेट क्या होता
है? आपको पता होना चाहिए। द फॉर्मेट इज
कुछ इस तरीके से जैसे ये आपका
ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग
चंग्ड
उसके बाद यहां पे क्या होती है बाय यहां
पे आपको द सेकंड थिंग इज़ कि आपको बाय
हेक्साडेसिमल में
चंक साइज देना होता है वो हमने दे दिया
उसके बाद एक्चुअल डेटा होता है एंड उसके
ज़ीरो से टर्मिनेट होती है। तो हमने
हेक्साडेसिमल में डेट वन दिखा दिया। बाइट
एक बाइ डेटा दे दी। X नाम की कोई भी रैंडम
डेटा और उसके बाद ज़ीरो नहीं दिखाया। वी
डिड नॉट गिव इट अ ज़ीरो। इसको हमने एंड
नहीं किया है। तो जब हमने एंड ही नहीं
किया है। फिर कैसे ये कम्युनिकेट कर
पाएगा? ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इट कैन नॉट
कम्युनिकेट।
तो हमने अगर मान लो यहां पे
ज़ीरो दे दिया
यहां पे। लेट्स सपोज़ वी गिवेन इट अ ज़ीरो।
हमने टर्मिनेट किया। इसको सेंड अप करते
हैं।
तो अब आ रहा है इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट।
क्योंकि अब ये नहीं आ रहा है कि कनेक्शन
टाइम्ड आउट। अब आ रही है इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट क्योंकि यह रिक्वेस्ट वैलिड
इसलिए नहीं है क्योंकि यहां पे हम जो है
वो कंटेंट लेंथ 10 पे काम कर रहे हैं एंड
ट्रांस कोडिंग चंक लेकिन कंटेंट लेंथ जो
है यहां पे ज्यादा है। इट्स मोर देन द
गिवन वैल्यू।
दैट्स द मेन थिंग। अब ये इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है।
तो अब इतना ये जो कांसेप्ट है समझ में आया
आपको? आप लोगों को यह समझ में आया बताइए।
लेट मी नो।
आर यू गेटिंग अंडरस्टुड यहां पे क्लियर है
क्योंकि इससे ज्यादा क्लेरिटी कि मैं क्या
दूं आपको? मैं बताऊं अब
थोड़ा-थोड़ा कुछ लोगों को कंफ्यूजन है।
अभी वापस से वीडियो आप देखेंगे तो आपको
समझ में आएगा। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है।
हां एक बार थोड़ा सा वापस से रिपीट करना
पड़ जाए शायद आपको।
देखो ऐसे भी होगा
बिल्कुल
तो दोनों टीईटी यूज़ करें तो आपको बताया ही
था ना आपको बताया था ना दोनों टीईटी जब
यूज़ होती है जब दोनों अगर मान लो ट्रांसफर
एंड कोडिंग है तो दोनों में से कोई एक ही
यूज़ होगा
एक को फॉल बैक कराना
एक को आपको
फॉल बैकक करा के ट्रांसफर इन मतलब एक का
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को अ यू को ऑफ फस्टकेट
करके एक का ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग हटा देना
पड़ेगा। जिसका हट जाएगा वो उस कंटेंट लेंथ
पे फॉल हो जाएगा। सिंपल एज सिंपल एज़ दैट
बस यही है।
हो गई। ये पूरा का पूरा यही कहानी था। लैब
तो हमने ख लैब तो पहले ही हमने सॉल्व कर
लिया है। लैब हैज़ बीन ऑलरेडी सॉल्वड। ये
तो अभी नॉट सॉल्व आ रहा है। वो तो ऐसे आ
रहा है। बट लैब सॉल्व हो चुकी है ऑलरेडी
आपकी। अब यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ 10 हमने
दिया है ना तो हमें 10 यहां पे कंटेंट
लेंथ पास करना पड़ता है। अगर नहीं करोगे
तो दिक्कत आएगी आपको। आपको कंटेंट लेंथ 10
अगर नहीं पास हुआ तो फिर इसको दिक्कत है।
सिंपल सा फंडा है। अब मान लो कि यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे मैंने दे दिया 1 2 3
अ 4 5 6 7 8 9 ये 10 ये कुछ ज्यादा ही
कंटेंट लेंथ ज्यादा ही प्रोवाइड हो गई है।
मतलब ज्यादा ही कंटेंट इसको मिल क्योंकि
इसके लिए तो ये पूरा का पूरा ही कंटेंट
लेंथ ही है। है ना? इसके लिए तो ये पूरा
का पूरा कंटेंट लेंथ है। इसके लिए कोई
मतलब नहीं है। वन क्या है? टू क्या है? x
क्या है? इससे कोई मतलब ही नहीं है। इट्स
टोटली कंटेंट लेंथ। तो अगर मैं इसको कम कर
दूं लाइक
ऐसे मैं कर दूं इसको देखो देखो जैसे कम कर
देते हैं इसको डी अब ये क्या हो गया
1 2 3 3 6 39 एंड a एंड वन इज़
एंड इसको भी हटा देते हैं फिर
है ना अब देखो यहां पे
अब देखो यहां पे अब मैं मान लो इसको
डिफ्रॉनिक्स को यहां पे ये रहने देते हैं
इसको हटा देते हैं ठीक है तो तो आप कंटेंट
लेंथ देख लो यहां पे। तीन तीन 6 और 3 9 ये
हो गए। और यहां पे एक 10 कर देते हैं। डी
डी इज़ द मेन मतलब एक जो है मेन आपका डी जो
बच गया वो आपका ये आपका डी है। तो ये
कंटेंट लेंथ को सेटिस्फाई कर रहा है। तो
यहां पे 10 का 10 यहां पे आपका आ जाएगा
यहां पे। अगर मैं इसको करके देखें कितने
हो रहे हैं बाइट? 10 हो रहे हैं। कंटेंट
लेंथ 10 है यहां पे। तो इसको ये बेसिकली
इसको सेटिस्फाई कर रहा है। ओनली दिस इज़
गेटिंग सेटिस्फाइड अह फॉर दिस। बट इट इज़
नॉट सेटिस्फाइंग अ चंग्ड डेटा। चंग्ड डेटा
को ये सेटिस्फाई नहीं कर पा रहा है। दैट्स
व्हाई देयर इज़ एन इशू ऑफ़ इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट। बस सिंपल ये सिंपल सा फंडा है।
तो इस तरीके से ये काम होती है। ये पूरा
का पूरा इस तरीके से ये जो TL C.tl
वालेबिलिटी थी। इस तरीके से हमने इसको
सॉल्व किया लैब अ इस वाले पर्टिकुलर लैब
को। एंड इसके साथ अब एक लैब कौन सी है जो
इससे थोड़ा सा और कॉम्प्लेक्स है वो है
आपका tcl फॉलबिलिटी दिस इज़ अ लिटिल बिट
मोर कॉम्प्लेक्स देन clt t डॉट
cl अब सोचो जब एक में इतना टाइम लगा है
आपको समझने में तो दूसरे में फिर कैसे ये
काम करेगा ठीक है चलिए अब यहां पे मैं इन
सारी चीजों को यहां पे हटा बता देता हूं।
कुछ लाइव में ट्राई करो। लाइव में भी
आएंगे भाई। लाइव में ऐसे जो तरीका है उसी
तरीके से हम जाते हैं कि पहले थ्यरी देन
लैब एंड देन लाइव टारगेट। राइट? तो वी विल
स्टिक टू दैट ओनली। ओके। सो यहां प्रॉक्सी
पे चलते हैं। कंट्रोल ए लेट्स क्लियर इट।
क्लियर हिस्ट्री क्लियर। यह क्लियर हो
गया। यहां पे आ जाते हैं। अब आ रहे हैं
यहां पे स्टीcl इस पे ओपन कर लेते हैं।
लेट्स ओपन इट।
लैब को एक्सेस कर लेते हैं।
इट्स गेटिंग एक्सेस्ड या लैब ओपन हो चुकी
है। नॉट सॉल्व। ठीक है।
अब देखो बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया ब्रदर। अब देखो
यहां पे आ जाते हैं सबसे नीचे यहां पे। अ
वेयर इज़ द एग्जैक्ट यह वाली गेट
रिक्वेस्ट? हमारी मेन जो यूआरएल है उसकी आ
गई। यहां पे यहां पे आ चुके हैं हम। यहां
पे इसको राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू रिपीटर
कर देते हैं। लेट्स गो टू द रिपीटर
सेक्शन। अब यहां पे हम रिपीटर सेक्शन पे आ
जाएंगे। अब देखो यहां पे अब जो ये जो
तुम्हारा तरीका है ये जो मेथड है इसमें
थोड़ा सा तुम्हें समझना पड़ेगा। ठीक है?
यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस कि ये कैसे काम
करता है। हाउ इट विल एग्जैक्टली हाउ अह अह
इट्स गोइंग टू वर्क। सो मैं रिपीटर पे आता
हूं। यहां पे ये रिपीटर पे आ चुके हैं। अब
ध्यान देना यहां पे थोड़ा सा ध्यान देना।
दिस इज नाउ
टीई डॉट
सीएल
वोरेबिलिटी।
इसमें क्या होगा? फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
विल
प्रायोरिटाइज
प्रायोरिटाइज द
किसको करेगा? ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग को
एंड बैक एंड टू
कंटेंट लेंथ।
बस यह इसमें हो रहा है। अब इसके लिए हमें
सिंपल सा फंडा क्या करना है? फिर से सारी
चीजें वही है। रिक्वेस्ट एट्रिब्यूट्स को
यहां एचटीपी वन पे लेकर आ जाएंगे।
देन रिक्वेस्ट मेथड को यहां पे चेंज
रिक्वेस्ट मेथड को यहां पे पोस्ट कर
देंगे। फालतू के जितने भी यहां पे हेडर्स
हैं इन सब की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। तो
इसको हम यहां से दफा कर देंगे। हटा दिया
हमने। दैट्स टोटली फाइन। कंटेंट लेंथ इज़
ज़ीरो क्योंकि कोई कंटेंट नहीं है। एंड
एवरीथिंग इज़ परफेक्टली नाउ फाइन। अब हम
यहां पे क्या करेंगे? व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू डू यहां पे हमें कंटेंट लेंथ के अलावा
यहां पे हमें ऐड करना है ट्रांसफर इन
कोडिंग अ जो हेडर होती है हमारी नॉर्मल
जिसको कि हम यूज़ करेंगे। एंड यहां से हम
अपडेट कंटेंट लेंथ वाली जो सिस्टम है इसको
पहले ही हटा देते हैं। सो वी विल रिमूव
इट। दैट्स इट। सिंपल। ठीक है? अब यहां
प्रिंटेबल जो नॉन प्रिंटेबल कररेक्टर्स है
इसको इनेबल कर देते हैं ताकि आपको यहां पे
सब कुछ दिखने लगेगी। यहां पे आपको सब कुछ
दिख रहा है। कंटेंट लेंथ के बाद सिंपल
यहां पे ये चीज़ आ रही है। अब यहां इसको
कोई रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। इसको हटाओ।
करंट लेंथ के बाद यहां पे डालेंगे
ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग। सो लेट्स ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग
एंड गिव इट चंग्ड। ठीक है? तो हमने यहां
पे हेडर डाल दिया ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग
चंग्ड। दैट्स इट। इसके बाद एक और न्यू
लाइन हम दे देंगे। इसके गैप दे देंगे बॉडी
के लिए। जो भी हमारी मेन जो भी हमारी बॉडी
में नेम नेम मेन चीजें आ रही हैं उसके लिए
हम दे दे रहे हैं। ठीक है? इट्स ऑल डन
नाउ। अब यहां पे हमें एक चीज ध्यान देना
है। इस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लोर
करने के लिए आप जब इसके पढ़ोगे दिस लैब
इनवॉल्व्स अ फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर
एंड द बैक एंड सर्वर डज़ नॉट सपोर्ट चंग्ड
इनकोडिंग। बैक एंड सर्वर क्या करता है?
क्लाइंट
अह सीएल कंटेंट लेंथ को सपोर्ट करता है।
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर रिजेक्ट्स रिक्वेस्ट दैट
आर नॉट यूज़िंग गेट ऑफ़ पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट।
मतलब फ्रंट एंड सर्वर जो है आपका वो
ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग को करता है। एंड बैक
एंड आपका जो है वो कंटेंट लेंथ को करता
है। टू सॉल्व द लैब स्मगल अ रिक्वेस्ट टू
द बैक एंड सर्वर सो दैट द नेक्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट प्रोसेस्ड बाय द बैक एंड सर्वर
अपीयरर्स टू यूज़ द मेथड जी पोस्ट। फिर वही
चीज़ जी पोस्ट लानी है आपको। कैसे भी करके
बस यही पूरा का पूरा आपका फंडा है। फिर
वही सारी चीजें दे रही है। सॉल्यूशन में
आप आएंगे अगेन तो इन्होंने सॉल्यूशन में
अगेन फिर से अ कुछ यहां पे लिख दिया है जो
आपको शायद समझ में नहीं आएगी कि ये
एग्जैक्टली है क्या? किस क्यों लिखा हुआ
है। तो इसको हम थोड़ा सा समझेंगे। ठीक है?
सो कंटेंट लेंथ इज़ यहां पे ज़ीरो। फिलहाल
के लिए ट्रांसफर कोडिंग इज़ चंग्ड। एंड
एवरीथिंग इज़ नाउ लेट्स सी व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू। अब यहां पे जो हमारा
मोटिव है इसको रिप्रोड्यूस करना है। द
रिप्रोड्यूस टू ब्रिंग इट एंड टू सी इफ द
फ्रंट एंड इज़ यूजिंग द ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग।
इसको हमें देखना है। तो हमने यहां पे
चंग्ड डाला हुआ है। वी हैव यूजिंग यू वी
आर यूजिंग चंग्ड। ठीक है? मैं यहां पे एक
और यहां पे मान लो एंटर देता हूं। आई एम
जस्ट गिविंग एंटर। ठीक है? और मैं इसको
सेंड करता हूं। लेट्स सी।
यहां पे क्या आ रहा है? एरर इनवैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट। यह एक इनवैलिड रिक्वेस्ट है।
यह एरर आ गई। ठीक है? अब मैं यहां पे एक
और
जो
डेटा है उसको भी यहां पे भेजने की कोशिश
करूंगा। वी विल ट्राई टू सेंड दिस
पर्टिकुलर डेटा आल्सो। बट व्हाई वी विल
सेंड दिस डेटा? वी विल सी कि यह डाटा
क्यों हम भेज रहे हैं? क्या इसकीेंस है?
क्यों? व्हाई इट इज़ेंट फॉर अस। तो यहां पे
हम क्या करेंगे? एक रिक्वेस्ट को यहां पे
डालेंगे। द रिक्वेस्ट क्या कौन सा
रिक्वेस्ट डालेंगे? जो रिक्वेस्ट हम यहां
से भेज रहे हैं। जो भी रिक्वेस्ट हम यहां
से भेज रहे हैं, व्हाटएवर रिक्वेस्ट वी आर
सेंडिंग। तो वी आर सेंडिंग करेंटली दिस
रिक्वेस्ट।
कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं है।
कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो है यहां पे। सो व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू डू अगर मैं यहां पे देखूं तो
ये चीज़ आ रही है। अनरकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड जी
पोस्ट करके यहां पे आपको मिलेगा जो कि
सिंपल सा फंडा है। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अब
एक और यहां पे हम रिक्वेस्ट इसमें ऐड
करेंगे। द रिक्वेस्ट वी आर गोइंग टू ऐड इज़
दिस वन।
यहां तक हमने कॉपी कर लिया।
एंड हियर वी आर गोइंग टू
एडिट। तो हमने यहां पे एक रिक्वेस्ट ऐड कर
दी। बाकी इन सबको हटा देते हैं। वी डोंट
नीड
दिस दिस एंड दिस एवरीथिंग। सो वी हैव एडेड
दिस वन। यहां होस्ट की हमें जरूरत फिलहाल
नहीं पड़ेगी क्योंकि होस्ट इज़ नॉट
रिक्वायर्ड। होस्ट तो आपका सिमिलर है। तो
होस्ट को भी हम हटा सकते हैं। ये हमारी दो
रिक्वेस्ट आ जा रही हैं आपकी। अब इन दोनों
रिक्वेस्ट में क्या डिफरेंस है? एंड क्यों
आपके लिए यह इतना इंपॉर्टेंट है? वो मैं
आपको बताता हूं। द फर्स्ट थिंग इज कि यहां
आप लोग इधर फोकस सभी लोग फोकस थोड़ा करके
रखिएगा। ठीक है? एवरीवन जस्ट क्ल जस्ट
फोकस हियर कि व्हाई इट इज़ सोेंट।
अब जब पहली रिक्वेस्ट आपकी जा रही है ना
ये पूरी रिक्वेस्ट है। पहली रिक्वेस्ट
आपकी ये वाली रिक्वेस्ट है।
ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग चंक् जो भी है यहां
पे। ठीक है? अब यहां से दूसरी रिक्वेस्ट
कौन सी है? दूसरी रिक्वेस्ट आपकी
ये वाली जो ये वाली आपकी दूसरी रिक्वेस्ट
है। ठीक है? तो यहां पे हमने क्या किया
है? कंटेंट लेंथ को फिलहाल के लिए हमने
क्या किया है? यहां पे ज़ीरो रखा है। वी
हैव पुट द कंटेंट लेंथ टू फिलहाल के लिए
ज़ीरो। जिसको कि हम चेंज करेंगे। वी विल
चेंज द कंटेंट लेंथ। सो टू व्हाट वी वी वी
विल चेंज इट। लेट्स सपोज़ कि हमारे पास
यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे जो नई
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है उस नई रिक्वेस्ट में
हम यहां पे एक न्यू लाइन दे देते हैं।
जस्ट गिविंग ए न्यू लाइन। ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग चंक्ड है। उसको हम यहां पे
टर्मिनेट कर देते हैं। अगेन न्यू लाइन
यहां पे एंड अगेन एक न्यू लाइन दे देते
हैं। दैट्स इट। कुछ इस तरीके का एक
रिक्वेस्ट हम बनाते हैं। अब इस रिक्वेस्ट
के अंदर में क्या हो रही है कि यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ कितना हो रहा है? यहां पे हाउ
मेनी कंटेंट लेंथ इज़ देयर? सो 1 2 3 अ
इसको अभी रहने देते हैं। इसको इसको छोड़ो।
इसको कंटेंट लेंथ को अभी छोड़ो। ऊपर वाले
आप ट्रांसफर कोडिंग की हम एक बार देखते
हैं। तो यहां पे जब ट्रांसफर कोडिंग है
चंग्ड में तो हियर द कंटेंट लेंथ इज़ नॉट
येट फिक्स्ड। हमारे पास कंटेंट लेंथ अभी
नहीं पता है। हमें क्या कंटेंट लेंथ हमें
डालना है। हमें क्या कंटेंट लेंथ चाहिए।
एंड यहां पे ये जो रिक्वेस्ट है सेकंड
रिक्वेस्ट इसकी अगर हम पूरी काउंटिंग करते
हैं। इफ यू विल काउंट द रिक्वेस्ट इट इज़
कमिंग अराउंड 92 इट इज़ कमिंग अराउंड 92
इट्स काइंड ऑफ़ 92 यहां पे आप राइट में
देखोगे यहां पे 92 लिखा हुआ आ रहा है। दिस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट पोस्ट करके जो आपके
पास आ रही है। राइट? सो अब हमें क्या करना
है? हमें यहां पर जो कंटेंट लेंथ है इसको
एज अ 92 का यू कैन से अ
हेक्स वैल्यू आपको यहां पे मेंशन करनी है।
द हेक्स वैल्यू ऑफ़ 92। तो हेक्स वैल्यू ऑफ़
92 क्या हो जाएगा भैया? वो एक हेक्स
वैल्यू क्रिएट हो जाएगी जो कि अ 5C आता है
यहां पे। आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे हेक्स
वैल्यू ऑफ़ 92 इज़ 5C. सो वी हैव टू पुट
यहां पे RN जो है आपके पास। इसके बाद आपको
एक और न्यू लाइन देनी है। एंड हियर यू हैव
टू पुट 5 C या 5C कैपिटल में लिख दो। कोई
फर्क नहीं पड़ता। वी डन डन डन इट हियर। अब
यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ हमारे पास कितनी आ
रही है? ये 1 2 3 4 तो इस कंटेंट लेंथ को
हम यहां पे चार कर देते हैं। वी पुट इट एट
फोर। तो अब वी हैव टू रिक्वेस्ट। सिंपल सा
दो फंडा है। दो रिक्वेस्ट है। कंटेंट ले
यहां पे चार है। तो अब जब ये रिक्वेस्ट
जाएगी तो tlc वन एबिलिटी है। ये सिंपल सा
फंडा है। तो ट्रांसफर इंकोडिंग को पहले
हमारा जो डील करेगा फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग में ये चंग्ड है। चंग्ड
में ये क्या करेगा?
यहां पे ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को जब यह प्रोसेस
कर रहा है। सो इट विल प्रोसेस एज़ अ चंग्ड।
चंग डेटा चंग्ड साइज़। चंक साइज़ यहां पे
क्या है? 5C है। 5C इज़ व्हाट? 92 ऑफ़ बाइट
ऑफ़ डेटा। तो, यह क्या करेगा? यहां से लेकर
और 92
यहां तक प्रोसेस कर देगा। पूरा का पूरा
डेटा प्रोसेस कर देगा। ये
एज सिंपल एज दैट। इट विल प्रोसेस ऑल द
डेटा। तो फ्रंट एंड डेट पूरा भेज दिया। अब
बैक एंड लेकिन जब बैक एंड के पास जाएगा तो
ये कंटेंट लेंथ फोर है यहां पे। इट्स
कंटेंट लेंथ फोर। तो इसमें से ये चार बाइट
ऑफ डेटा को रीड कर रहा है।
जब बैक एंड के पास जा रही है तो ये चार
बाइट ऑफ़ डेटा को रीड कर रहा है। ऐसे तो ये
पूरा आ गया। पूरा का पूरा यहां पे हमारे
सामने अ फ्रंट एंड ने क्या किया? ट्रांस
कोडिंग करके और हमारे फ्रंट एंड ने भैया
ने इसको भेज दिया। वी गॉट द अह पूरा का
पूरा। बट जैसे ही बैक एंड के पास जाएगा
बैक एंड इज ऑपरेटिंग ऑन द फोर कंटेंट
लेंथ। द लेंथ इज फोर।
सो हाउ इट इज़ सीइंग द लेंथ? तो वन
ये आपकी क्योंकि कंटेंट लेंथ है। तो
कंटेंट लेंथ स्टार्टिंग से ही आपका शुरू
हो जाएगा। 1 2 3 4 यहां तक बस। उसके बाद
ये पोस्ट जो है ना पोस्ट ये पूरा का पूरा
पोस्ट जो है यह वैसा का वैसा ही रहेगा एज
अ न्यू रिक्वेस्ट।
तो क्या हमारे पास पहले से कोई डेटा बची
हुई है?
डू वी हैव एनी डेटा? तो उसके लिए हमें
यहां पे इस रिक्वेस्ट को क्या रिक्वेस्ट
बना के भेजना होगा? जी पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
बना के भेजना होगा। जी पोस्ट।
सो दैट सो दैट व्हाट विल हैपन? द फर्स्ट
ट्रांसफरेंट कोडिंग चंक्ड विल हैपन। तो
क्या होगा यहां पे? यह ट्रांसफरेंट कोडिंग
जी पोस्ट यह पूरा का पूरा जी पोस्ट
भेजेगा। सो इट्स अ काइंड ऑफ़ जी पोस्ट अब
जब आ जा रही है यहां पे जी देखो अब जी
पोस्ट जब हमने कर दिया तो यहां पे ये 5D
हो गया। 93 बाइट्स ऑफ़ डेटा हो गई। तो हमें
यहां पे ये 5D करना पड़ेगा। वी हैव टू डू
इट 5D। तो मैं यहां पे
5D कर देता हूं। डन। तो यह 5D पूरा का
पूरा भेज दिया। अब इसमें जो यह पूरा का
पूरा डाटा गया है आपके साइड से। अब जब यह
कंटेंट लेंथ पे आएगी तो कंटेंट लेंथ यहां
पे फोर है। तो इट विल कंसीडर 1 2 3 4
बट बट यह भी तो देखो कि दूसरी जो
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है जी पोस्ट ये एक फ्रेश
रिक्वेस्ट है। इसका अपना एक कंटेंट लेंथ
है यहां पे। एंड दिस कंटेंट शुड रीड
द प्रीवियस अपेंडेंट कंटेंट। तो उसके लिए
यहां पे कितनी वैल्यू देनी पड़ेगी? तो यहां
पे मान लो हमारे पास है 1 2 ये टोटल
वैल्यू है सात। ये टोटल हमारे पास सेवन
सेवन आ रही है। यहां पे सेवन आ रही है। तो
यहां पे हमें इसको
एट देनी पड़ेगी।
व्हाई? सो ताकि वो क्या करे कि एक दो यहां
पे कंटेंट लेंथ में आपका काउंट करो
नहीं कंटेंट लेंथ ये सॉरी दिस विल नॉट बी
काउंटेड यहां पे ये काउंट होगा कंटेंट
लेंथ का ये 1 2 3 4 5 पांच हो रही है तो
यहां पे आपको छह देनी पड़ेगी छह सिक्स
क्योंकि ये न्यू लाइन काउंट नहीं होगी
ऑब्वियस सी बात है ये नई रिक्वेस्ट है ये
जी पोस्ट एक टोटली न्यू रिक्वेस्ट है तो
यहां पे ये काउंट होगी कैसे 1 2 3 4 5 एंड
एक और इसमें यह डाटा लेगा एक और अपेंड
करेगा वह अपेंड कौन सा करेगा जो यह बच गया
था आपका
जी पोस्ट यही तो बचा था हमारे पास जो कि
अपेंड नहीं हुआ था पहले दिस वाज़ द थिंग
दैट वाज़ नॉट अपेंडेड। क्यों? क्योंकि
कंटेंट लेंथ फोर थी। तो यहां पे ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। जब पहली बार गया था तो चंग्ड
हुआ था। तो चंग्ड में क्या हुआ था? ज़ीरो
पे बंद हो के यह पूरा का पूरा ही सेंड हो
चुका था। पूरा का पूरा सेंड हो चुका था।
कंटेंट लेंथ में यहां से लेके जी पोस्ट से
लेके यानी ये पूरा का पूरा जो डेटा है वो
93 बाइट जो है वो पूरी सेंड हो चुकी थी।
एज सिंपल एज दैट। अब मैं इसको अगर मैं
सेंड करूंगा इफ आई विल सेंड इट।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग।
री टाइम आउट आ रही है। सो व्हाट आई विल डू
अ आई विल रिमूव दिस पर्टिकुलर जी। मैं
यहां पे जी अभी हटा देता हूं यहां पे। एंड
यहां पे इसको सेंड करके देखते हैं व्हाट
इज़ हैपनिंग।
लेट्स सी।
अभी देखो यह टाइम आउट आएगा। कनेक्शन टाइम
आउट रीड टाइम आउट आ चुका। अब ये मुझे
बताइए कि ये रीड टाइम आउट ऑप्शन ये जो रीड
टाइम आउट है ये क्यों आ रहा है अभी? व्हाई
इट इज कमिंग रीड टाइम आउट? मुझे कोई जिसको
थोड़ा ज्यादा समझ में आ रहा है बताइए। आप
लोग को समझ में आ रहा है ना? तो मुझे
बताइए व्हाई इट इज कमिंग रीड टाइम आउट?
कोई बता सकता है एनीवन?
जीरो नहीं किया काउंट कौन सा जीरो
काउंट हुआ ना जीरो तो
जीरो से टर्मिनेट नहीं किया रिक्वेस्ट को
कौन सी रिक्वेस्ट को नहीं टर्मिनेट बताइए
कर तो दिया है जीरो से टर्मिनेट अब कौन सी
टर्मिनेशन होगी
अच्छा हां अच्छा 5C होगा
5C होगा ऐसा 5C क्यों होगा
हां सेकंड वन इज़ अनदर रिक्वेस्ट राइट
सेकंड वन इज़ अनदर रिक्वेस्ट बिल्कुल सही
चलो इन्होंने बोला फाइव सी होगा चलो मैं
फाइव सी डाल देता हूं यहां पे सेंड करते
हैं लेट्स
सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट
एंड लेट्स सी द रिस्पांस अगेन कुछ खास
नहीं है। राइट
एरर रीड टाइम आउट
एरर रीटाइम आउट आ रही है।
G हटाए तो 5C होगा। ठीक है? हां, G हटा
दिया। सॉरी। ठीक है, ठीक है। गॉट इट। गॉट
इट। तो G हटा दिया यहां पे और यहां पे 5C
कर दिया 92। बिल्कुल सही है। ठीक है। तो
5C करके यहां पे हमने सेंड किया। एंड
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग हियर? इट इज़ अगेन कमिंग
अ रीड टाइम आउट। ऐसा ऐसा रीटाइम आउट आ रहा
है।
देखो रीटाइम आउट आ रहा है।
हम अब देखो
रीड टाइम आउट आने का एक सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट रीज़न है। यहां पे अभी देखो अभी
तक रिस्पांस ही नहीं आया। इसको मैं कैंसिल
कर दूंगा। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
इसका एक सबसे बड़ा रीजन है यहां पर द रीजन
वी हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड
द रीज़न वी हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड हियर मैं
इसको यहां पे कैंसिल कर देता हूं यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए मैं क्या कर देता हूं इस
पूरी रिक्वेस्ट जो भी ये रिक्वेस्ट ये जो
एक नई रिक्वेस्ट बन रही है ना नई
रिक्वेस्ट ताकि आपको कंफ्यूजन ना हो मैं
इसको यहां पे कंट्रोल x करके यहां से हटा
देता हूं
ठीक है सॉरी यहां मैंने हटा दिया इसको एक
नए रिक्वेस्ट में http रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे
कर देते हैं इसको इसको पेस्ट कर देते हैं।
ठीक है? यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से कंटेंट
लेंथ अ सिक्स यहां पे जो भी है वो कर दिया
हमने। यहां पे न्यू लाइन जो हमने देना है
वो दे दिया। ठीक है? ये एक न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
की तरह हम इसको कंसीडर कर लेते हैं।
एप्लीकेशन फॉर्म ये सब चीजें। अब इसमें
क्योंकि हमें न्यू रिक्वेस्ट है तो हमें
यह होस्ट ऐड करना पड़ेगा। बिकॉज़ होस्ट इज़
देयर।
क्योंकि यहां पर होस्ट के बिना तो यह
रिक्वेस्ट काम करेगी नहीं। तो मैंने यहां
पे होस्ट डाल दिया।
ठीक है?
ओके। सो यहां पे ये होस्ट आ गई आपकी।
एसटीडी रिक्वेस्ट होस्ट आ गई आपकी। कंटेंट
टाइप आपकी जो थी वो आ गई आपकी। यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ आपका आ गया। अब यहां पे क्या
करना है? अब मैं इसको आपको थोड़ा सा
समझाने की कोशिश करता हूं। यहां पे पहले
वाले में गए। यहां पे व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग
हियर? तो यहां पे हमने 5C सैश R एन चंक ये
सब कर दिया। क्योंकि हमारे पास बहुत सारे
वो थे
इनकोडिंग्स थी। मतलब डेटा थे। बेसिकली ये
डेटा जो थे वो डेटा थे इसलिए हमने यहां पे
ये सारी चीजें कर दिया। अब इसको मैं यहां
पे रिमूव कर देता हूं।
इसको जस्ट जस्ट वी आर रिमूविंग। एंड लेट्स
पुट इट एट कंटेंट लेंथ।
यहां पे फोर यहां पर कंटेंट लेंथ है। मैं
यहां पे फिलहाल जीरो कर देता हूं। एंड
इसको मैं सेंड करता हूं। लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज हैपनिंग।
लेट्स सी द रिजल्ट।
कोई रिजल्ट नहीं आ रहा। नथिंग इज़ देयर।
रीटाइम आउट आ गई यहां पे। क्योंकि यहां पे
क्या आ रहा है? चंग्ड जो है यहां पे हमने
दे दिया है अचंग को हमने यहां पे क्लज़
नहीं करा है। वी हैव नॉट क्लोज द चंग्ड
थिंग। तो अगर मैं यहां पे चंग्ड को क्लज़
कर दूं लेट्स सपोज़ अ ज़ीरो एंड ज़ीरो
व्हाटएवर कि चंग्ड भैया आप भी क्लोज हो
जाइए। ये कंड ज़ीरो जाहिर है चंग्ड भी ज़ीरो
हो जाइए। अगर मैं ऐसे करता हूं तो व्हाट
विल हैपन। लेट्स सी। लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग।
अगेन एरर टाइम आउट आ रही है। अब मैं यहां
पर एक और न्यू लाइन देता हूं क्योंकि चंक
को एक न्यू लाइन की जरूरत होती है। तो अब
मैं जैसे ही न्यू लाइन देता हूं यहां पे
ये चंक्ड चल चुका है हमारा एंड हमारा चंक
जो है वो काम कर चुका है। अब ये सब कुछ
प्रोसेस कर रही है। जो भी चीजें हमारी जो
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग और इसमें होती है कि
कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो है। तो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर
जो है ज़ीरो कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे उसको मिल
रहा है। ठीक है? बिल्कुल परफेक्ट फाइन है।
एंड जो है आपका बैक एंड सर्वर है वो
कंटेंट लेंथ को कर रहा है। और फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर आपका ट्रांसफर कोडिंग कर रहा है। तो
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर ने चंग्ड किया। चंग्ड
इसको ज़ीरो मिल चुकी है। दैट्स टोटली फाइन।
एंड देयर इज़ नथिंग नो डेटा फाइन। उसके बाद
कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो। कंटेंट लेंथ भी यहां पे
ज़ीरो आ गई है। उसके बाद भी कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है क्योंकि कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे ज़ीरो
है। कंटेंट में कुछ है नहीं। तो यहां तक
बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है। बिल्कुल फाइन है। अब
इसी में अगर हम थोड़ा बहुत चेंज करें। थोड़ा
सा चेंज ये कर देंगे कि हम फ्रंट एंड में
ट्रांस कोडिंग को यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो सही
है। अब कंटेंट लेंथ को मैं अगर यहां पे वन
कर देता हूं। लेट्स सपोज़ इफ आई एम गोइंग
टू डू द कंटेंट लेंथ एज़ वन। और अब मैं
इसको सेंड करता हूं। सो सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग। ये क्या आ रहा है?
अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड ज़ीरो पोस्ट।
क्या आ रहा है? अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड ज़ीरो
पोस्ट। सो, इट इज़ सिंपली कमिंग कि यह कोई
मेथड नहीं है। दिस इज़ ज़ीरो पोस्ट। मेथड।
दैट्स इट। क्यों? क्योंकि हमने बस यहां पर
कंटेंट लेंथ को वन किया है। फ्रंट एंड का
जो सर्वर है वो वन कंटेंट लेंथ खोज रहा
है। फ्रंट एंड वाला। अब वन जो खोज रहा है
भैया वो कहां से लाएगा? वन वन खोज रहा है।
पहले गई वन के पास वन इसके पास। अब वन
उसको एक कंटेंट लेन ज़ीरो मिल गया। अब ये
ज़ीरो जो है यह जैसे ही ज़ीरो है। यह हमारा
किस में अपेंड हो गया? पोस्ट में। क्योंकि
एक एक न्यू वो है।
अब यहां पर जब हम पोस्ट वैल्यूस पर
जाएंगे, यह नॉर्मल यह नॉर्मल सा सिनेरियो
हो गया आपका। अब हम यहां पर चलते हैं न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट पे यहां पे। ठीक है? ये न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट पे चलते हैं। यहां पे सब कुछ
पुराना है। यहां पे एक न्यू रिक्वेस्ट है
जिस पे हम जाने वाले हैं। कंटेंट लेंथ को
यहां पे हम फिलहाल के लिए ज़ीरो ही रखते
हैं। वी विल बी कीपिंग इट एस ज़ीरो। सो इफ
वी विल सेंड इट। सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी।
इसको हटाओ
प्रॉक्सी पे इसको ओपन सेंड टू रिपीटर कर
लेते हैं। यहां पे आ जाते हैं। कहां गया
रिपीटर में? हां ये रही। इसको मैं यहां पे
गेट चेंज रिक्वेस्ट मेथड पोस्ट कर दिया
मैंने यहां पे। एंड बाकी सारी चीजें जो है
यहां से यहां तक के हटा देते हैं।
एवरीथिंग इज अ सॉरी सॉरी
हम एवरीथिंग इज़ परफेक्टली फाइंड।
यहां पे हमने न्यू नॉन प्रिंटेबल करक्टर्स
को इनेबल कर दिया। कंटेन ज़ीरो और यहां पे
सेंड करते हैं। अब यहां पे हम सेंड करेंगे
यहां पे। ओके एवरीथिंग इज़ फाइन। गुड।
बढ़िया। तो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू यहां
पे
पहले वाले पे आते हैं। अनरकॉग्नाइज जीरो
पोस्ट आ रही है। अब यहां पे ये ज़ीरो हो
गई। ठीक है? क्योंकि यहां पे हमने कंटेंट
लेंथ वन डिफाइन कर दिया है। दैट्स व्हाई
इट इज़ गिविंग यू द ज़ीरो। अब यहां पे हमने
यहां पे ज़ीरो कर दिया और सेंड कर दिया। अब
देखो क्या होगा? बिल्कुल परफेक्ट। कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है। आराम से चल रही है। अब
मैं यहां पे जाके अगर इसको सेंड करूंगा तो
इट इज़ टेलिंग यू अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड मेथड ज़ीरो
पोस्ट। क्योंकि हमने यहां पे ज़ीरो रखा है।
ठीक है? बिल्कुल परफेक्टली फाइन है।
बिल्कुल कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। हमने यहां पे
ज़ीरो कर दिया है। अब यहां पे जब हम जाएंगे
तो ये इसी ज़ीरो को ही तो कंसीडर कर रहा
है। अब ये ज़ीरो कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो यहां पे।
ठीक है भाई? ज़ीरो कर लिया। तो लेकिन जो
फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है वो ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को
कर रहा है। ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग यहां पे जो
आपको मिल रही है वो चंग्ड है। चंग्ड यहां
पे ज़ीरो खत्म हो जा रही है। बात आ जा रही
है कंटेंट लेंथ पे। कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो है।
कुछ भी नहीं है। तो, यह जीरो पोस्ट
क्योंकि जीरो इज ज़ीरो। तो, यहां पे जीरो
पोस्ट इसमें अपेंड हो जा रहा है। क्योंकि
यहां पे ज़ीरो के बाद कंटेंट लेंथ में एक
आपकी मिल जा रही है ज़ीरो। यहां पे आपको
ज़ीरो है। अब मैं अगर यही सेम चीज़ सिमिलर
चीज़ अगर मैं इसको थोड़ा सा घुमा दूं। मैं अ
लिटिल बिट ऑफ़
मॉडिफिकेशन अगर हम इसको करने की कोशिश
करें। व्हाट वी कैन डू? इस कंटेंट लेंथ को
मान लो हमने क्या कर दिया? यहां से हटाया
और इसको चार कर दिया।
वी डीड इट फोर। कंटेंट लेंथ को हमने चार
कर दिया। ट्रांसफर कोडिंग चंक् ही रहने
दिया। सब कुछ यहां पे हमने ऐसे ही रहने
दिया। अब हम यहां पे क्या करेंगे?
अब हम यहां पे जो हमने ये दिया हुआ है तो
ये क्या कंसीडर करेगा? चार। 1
2 3 4 यह यहां तक की जो डाटा है उसको
भेजेगा।
स्टार्टिंग के चार
यह उसको भेजेगा।
अब यहां पे जो नई रिक्वेस्ट है, इसमें जो
नई रिक्वेस्ट है, यहां पे हम क्या करेंगे?
वी आर गोइंग टू डू कि हमने यहां पे कंटेंट
लेंथ यहां पे ज़ीरो जो मेंशन करा है, तो हम
यहां पे एक नया डेटा बेसिकली इसको हम नया
डेटा एक भेज रहे हैं। एक नई डाटा आ रही
है। तो, इसके पास कौन सी डाटा है? यह जो
एक नई रिक्वेस्ट आई है ना, एक नई
रिक्वेस्ट। तो हम इसको हम नई रिक्वेस्ट के
तौर पे क्या कर लेते हैं कि यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ को सिक्स कर देते हैं मान लो
और इसको सिक्स बाइट का बना देते हैं। 6
बाइट का मतलब अ दिस इज़ 1 2 3 4 5 6 यहां
पे सिक्स बाइट बन गए यहां पे। या इसको ऐसे
कर दो। यहां पे ज़ीरो दे दो।
ट्रांसफर कोडिंग को अगर तुम्हें वो करना
है, चेंज करना है मतलब हटाना है। ट्रांसफर
कोडिंग को वो करना है तो यहां पे 6 बाइट
की डेटा बस चाहिए। तो हमें यहां पे 6 बाइट
की डेटा मिल चुकी है। अब 6 बाइट की डेटा
कुछ भी तुम यहां पे कोई भी रैंडम वैल्यू
डाल दो। एक कोई एक x डाल दो। तो 1 2 यहां
पे आ गई तीन 4 5
कुछ इस तरीके से। ये सिक्स ये सिक्स बाइट
की मान लो यहां पे डेट आ चुकी है। लेट्स
सपोज 6 बाइट की डेट। तो 1 2 3 4 5 यहां पे
xy डाल दो। छह हो गई। 1 2 3 4 5 6 ये 6
बाइट की यहां पे डाटा बन चुकी है यहां पे।
बस इतना समझ में आ गया। यह तो क्लियर हो
गया होगा। अब यह 6 बाइट की डाटा यहां पे आ
चुकी है। अब इसी
हम रिपीटर पे पहली वाली रिक्वेस्ट पे
जाएंगे। ठीक है? तो हम यहां पे अब सेंड
करते हैं। इट विल गिव यू 200 ओके। नेक्स्ट
वाले पे जाते हैं। इसको हम सेंड करते हैं।
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। यहां पे 200
ओके आ रहा है। बिल्कुल परफेक्टली फाइन आ
रहा है यहां पे। यहां पे कोई भी आपको
प्रॉब्लम या इशू नहीं आ रही है। अब इसको
एचटीटीp वन में चेंज करना है। इसकी जो
चेंज है एचटीटीp वन में आपको चेंज करनी
है। यह बिल्कुल मैंडेटरी है। उसको अब सेंड
करना है।
नथिंग
200 ओके आया। अब हम यहां पर चलते हैं।
इसको हम सेंड करते हैं।
इट विल गिव 300 200 ओके एंड इफ विल सेंड
इट
इट विल गिव यू 200 ओके क्योंकि यहां पर अब
कंटेंट लेंथ जो है यहां पर द कंटेंट लेंथ
यहां पर जो हमने यहां पर डिफाइन किया है
वह 1 2 3 4 5 6 है तो मैं यहां पे यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स दे देता हूं सिक्स इट
इज़ इट इज़ नाउ सिक्स एंड नाउ इफ वी विल गो
एंड सेंड इट हियर
तो यहां पे ये चार यहां पे जो रीड कर रहा
है और यहां पे हम सेंड करते हैं लेट्स सी
छह को कंटेन सिक्स इज़ तो यहां पे भी अभी
ये रीड कर रहा है। अब यहां पे इसी
रिक्वेस्ट को ये जो हमारी पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट है इसको हमने यहां से कॉपी
किया। वी आर जस्ट कॉपीिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर
होल रिक्वेस्ट। हमने यहां से यहां से हमने
इसको कंट्रोल एक्स करके मतलब व्हाटएवर
यहां से कॉपी कर लिया। एंड यहां पे एज इसी
को एज अ न्यू रिक्वेस्ट हम यहां पे
इंप्लीमेंट करेंगे। एज अ न्यू रिक्वेस्ट।
हमने एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजा तो यहां पे 200
ओके आ गया यहां पे। अब इसको जब एज अ न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट सेंड करेंगे तो न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
जब भी सेंड होगी तो आपकी ट्रांसफर
इनकोडिंग चंग्ड जो है ये एक आपका
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट हो गया। दिस इज़ वन वन
ऑफ़ योर पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट। नाउ देयर वुड
बी अनदर रिक्वेस्ट जो कि इसके नीचे से
स्टार्ट होगी आपकी एंड ये यहां से हम इसको
स्टार्ट करते हैं।
पोस्ट से।
दिस दैट इज इट।
अब क्योंकि इसमें होस्ट की रिक्वायरमेंट
नहीं है। सेम होस्ट आपका ऑपरेट हो रहा है।
तो हम होस्ट को यहां से रिमूव कर देंगे।
होस्ट विल बी रिमूव्ड। बस तो ये अब होस्ट
आपका क्लियर हो गया। यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ
यहां पे चार आपने दिया है। ट्रांसपेरेंट
कोडिंग जंक किया है। अब कंटेंट लेंथ चार
के अकॉर्डिंग काम करेंगे। तो यहां पे हमने
क्या किया?
व्हाट वी डिड? हमने यहां से ये जो चीज है
इसको हटा देते हैं। ये जो कंटेंट लेंथ ये
जो xy वाली चीज है क्योंकि ऑलरेडी एक
रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे अपेंड हुई है। तो इसको
हमने हटा दिया। अब हमारे पास टोटल कंटेंट
लेंथ क्या है? एक 1 2 3 4 5 यहां पे पांच
है। तो जब भी देंगे पांच से एक बढ़ा के
देंगे तो ये यहां पे छह हो जाएगी। तो छह
जब यहां पर हो जाएगी तो अब जब यह एक नई
रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे क्योंकि देखो यह एक
अलग रिक्वेस्ट है। यह जो ट्रांसफरिंग
कोडिंग चंग्ड हो रही है तो चंग्ड के बाद
यहां पे क्या हो रहा है? चंग्ड के बाद इट
इज़ सिंपली यू हैव टू मेक इट गिव इट अ
बाइट। कितने बाइट का डेटा है? कितने बाइट
का ये डेटा होना चाहिए? ये चंक्ड के बाद
आपको उसकी साइज बतानी है। तो ये पूरा का
पूरा रिक्वेस्ट ये साइज ही तो है। पूरा का
पूरा ये रिक्वेस्ट
ये पूरा का पूरा रिक्वेस्ट साइज है।
यही तो आपको बतानी है। तो पूरा भेजेंगे
हम। तो हम इसको क्या रिक्वेस्ट भेजेंगे?
जी पोस्ट करके भेजेंगे। जी पोस्ट। इस
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजेंगे।
तो जब जी पोस्ट वाली रिक्वेस्ट को भेजेंगे
तो इसको जब हम काउंट करेंगे इट विल कम टू
93 5D इट विल कम टू द 935D
ये कुछ इस तरीके से आएगा
अब ये क्यों अब ये 935D ऐसा कैसे आ रहा है
किस तरीके से आ रहा है क्योंकि हमने यहां
पे जी पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट को भेज रहा है वी
आर सेंडिंग जी पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट
तो इट्स कमिंग
टोटल जो आपकी वो आ रही है डेटा काउंट आ
रही है वो डेटा काउंट आपका आ रहा है 93
दैट इज अ 5d
दैट्स इट तो अब एक बार हम यहां पे क्या
देख सकते हैं कि
यहां पे अब हम इसको यहां मेंशन करेंगे 5D
को सो वी विल एंटर
एंड यहां पे एंटर कर देंगे 5D तो यह हमारा
हो
यह हमारी डन। दिस इज़ नाउ डन।
सो इफ वी विल सेंड इट व्हाट विल हैपन।
लेट्स सी इन रिस्पांस देखते हैं क्या आता
है। इन रिस्पांस इन द रिस्पांस व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग। लेट्स सी
इट्स टाइम गेटिंग टाइम आउट।
इट्स रीड टाइम आउट। अब यह रीड टाइम आउट
आने का यहां पे मेन रीज़न अब क्या हो गया?
हमने तो यहां पे चार इनकोडिंग दी। बिल्कुल
परफेक्टली कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। यहां पे
चार इनकोडिंग दी हमने चलेगा। अब यहां पे
हमने चार इनकोडिंग चार कंटेंट लेंथ यहां
पे दिया है। तो पहली रिक्वेस्ट जब जा रही
है आपके फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के पास तो चंक्ड
इनकोडिंग कर रही है प्रोसेस एंड ये 5D को
प्रोसेस कर रही है। 5D में आपकी ये पूरी
की पूरी
जो डाटा है वो प्रोसेस हो जा रही है जो कि
93 बाइट्स की है। एग्जैक्ट बाइट की आपकी
जो 93 बाइट की आप दिखा रहे थे। हम जो दिखा
रहे थे बेसिकली वो यहां पर हमने पूरी कर
दी। दैट्स इट। खत्म। अब इसके बाद बैक एंड
सर्वर के पास डेट आ जाएगी जो कि कंटेंट
लेंथ पे काम करेगी। अब कंटेंट लेंथ बैक
एंड के पास छह है तो 1 2 तो यहां पे क्या
आ रही है? ये 1 2 3 4 5 तो एक यहां से ये
जी को उठा लेगी। कहेगी भैया जी जो है उसको
हम उठाएंगे।
अब वह जी को अपेंड करेगी और अपेंड करके जो
है आपको वहां पर रिजल्ट दे देगी कि भैया
यह जो है यह अपेंड हो चुकी है। अब इसमें
एक दिक्कत प्रॉब्लम यह है कि व्हाई इट इज
नॉट गिविंग अस द जी पोस्ट थिंग। यह मुझे
कोई बताइए तो मैं समझूंगा कि आपको समझ में
आ गया। व्हाई इट इज नॉट गिविंग जी पोस्ट?
लेट मी नो। आई एम आस्किंग टू एवरीबडी। सभी
से मैं पूछ रहा हूं। तो बताइए मुझे।
बताइए
समझ में आ रही है आपको किसी को?
लेट मी नो गाइस। आई एम सीइंग द चैट
सेक्शन। प्लीज बताइए जल्दी से बताइए।
कंफ्यूजिंग हो गया क्या कंफ्यूजिंग हो गया
बताओ
बताओ क्या कंफ्यूजिंग हो गया स्क्रीन
अच्छा स्क्रीन नहीं शो हो रही है क्या हां
ये बताओ यहां पे यहां पे रीड टाइम आउट
क्यों आ रहा है व्हाई इट इज नॉट जस्ट
गिविंग कि हां भैया हो गया जी पोस्ट
वाली यार
चीजें क्यों नहीं कंसीडर हो रही है ये
इसका
वो कोई भी बता दो तो मैं समझ जाऊंगा कि
व्हाट इज नॉट हैपनिंग
हम हम हम [हंसी]
बताइए बताइए
5 सीl
में चार है इसलिए हां तो cl में क्या होना
चाहिए cl में क्या होना चाहिए बताइए
ठीक है? कंटेंट लेंथ में चार है। चलो ठीक
है। मैं समझ गया। मान लिया कि कंटेंट लेंथ
में चार है। तो यहां पर क्या होना चाहिए?
व्हाट इट शुड बी?
अच्छा ठीक है। तो यहां पे सीएल में
आयुष एंड शिवम इस सेइंग कि सीएल में पांच
कीजिए। ठीक है? चलो बहुत बहुत बढ़िया।
मैंने सीएल में पांच कर दिया। इसका मतलब
क्या हुआ? इसका मतलब ये क्या हुआ? कि यह
जो फ्रंट एंड सर्वर है ट्रांसफरेंट कोडिंग
करके अ 5d को प्रोसेस करके पूरा प्रोसेस
कर देगा। यहां पे खत्म हो जाएगी। ये एंड
हो जाएगी क्योंकि ज़ीरो है। एंड दिस इज़ डन।
नाउ बिकॉज़ कंटेंट लेंथ पे फॉल होगी। बैक
एंड सर्वर आपकी राइट? तो बैक एंड सर्वर
पांच को काउंट करेगी क्योंकि यह सीएल में
जी नहीं आ रहा है। ठीक है? तो पांच को
काउंट करेगी। सो व्हाट विल हैपन? अ 1 2 3
4 एंड द जी द जी अब मैं इसको सेंड करता
हूं। एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग।
क्या हुआ? देखते हैं। रीड टाइम आउट। अब ये
वापस से रीटाइम आउट आ रहा है। ऐसा क्यों?
मैंने तो यहां से आपके कहने पर इस चार को
पांच कर दिया।
बट बट बट देखो बट सोचने वाली बात यहां पे
क्या है? सोचने वाली बात यह है ये जो
कंटेंट लेंथ है ये एक पहली रिक्वेस्ट है।
दिस इज द अदर रिक्वेस्ट। जो हमारे पास
यहां से जो जी पोस्ट निकल के आ रही है,
दिस इज़ द अदर रिक्वेस्ट।
दिस इज़ द अदर रिक्वेस्ट ना। तो ये
रिक्वेस्ट तो अलग है ना ये वाली। तो आप
उसको इससे कंफ्यूज क्यों कर रहे हो? मुझे
यह समझ नहीं आ रही है। यह चीज मुझे समझ
नहीं आ रहा। आई एम गिविंग अ फर्स्ट
रिक्वेस्ट एज अ पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जो कि
कंटेंट लेंथ फोर और ट्रांसफर कोडिंग चंग्ड
को डिनोट कर रही है यहां पे। अब यहां पे
चंग्ड क्योंकि ये फ्रंट एंड सर्वर के पास
जाके पहले चंग्ड को प्रोसेस करेगी। तो
चंग्ड को इसने प्रोसेस किया। अब चंग्ड को
प्रोसेस करने पे व्हाट दिस इज गिविंग अस
कि चंग्ड यहां से ये पूरी आपकी चंग्ड है।
ये देखो
सॉरी
ये पूरी आपकी चंग है।
ओके
ओके नीचे सीएल में फाइव करके देखिए ठीक है
फाइव कर दिया हमने
अब मैं सेंड करता हूं यहां पे
गिविंग द फाइव एंड सेंडिंग
ठीक है सीएल5 कर दिया सेकंड में इसको से
वो सेम रहेगी उससे कुछ होगा नहीं सेम
रहेगा ये
ये सेम रहेगी क्योंकि ये एरर टाइम आउट फिर
से वही यही सेम चीज आएगी। एरर टाइम आउट।
ये एरर टाइम आउट आएगी। इसका देखो
इसका सिंपल सा एक मैं आपको समझाता हूं।
सिंपल सा एक फंडा है। जी पोस्ट है, जी
होस्ट है। उससे कुछ भी वहां पे लिख दो। जी
पोस्ट लिख दो। व्हाटएवर कुछ भी एनीथिंग यू
कैन राइट इट डाउन। यहां कांसेप्ट समझने की
बात है यहां पे। दैट्स इट। पहले हमें
कांसेप्ट समझना है। उसके बाद ही कुछ हो
पाएगा। अदरवाइज नहीं हो पाएगा। कांसेप्ट
यहां पे सिंपल सा है कि आपको यहां पे
ये पूरी की पूरी 5 डी ये जो लाइन है ना ये
लाइन इसको ये 1 2 3 4 कंसीडर किया है। ठीक
है? और इसके नीचे जब ये चंग्ड के बाद यह
जो लाइन आ रही है आपकी यह आपकी न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे ये आपकी स्मगल
रिक्वेस्ट मान के चल लो कि ये आपकी जा रही
है जो कि न्यू रिक्वेस्ट के तौर पे आपकी
पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट में ऐड होगी। तो ये जा
रही है आपकी। अब चंग्ड जब हो रहा है जब
ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग हमने चंग्ड यहां पे
मेंशन कर दिया है। तो चंग्ड डेटा आपकी यही
तो जा रही है चंग्ड डेटा।
दिस इज द चंक डाटा
डॉप की जा रही है यहां पर बट यह जो चंक्
डाटा है दिस इज ऑफ 93
बाइट्स टोटल आपकी जो है बेसिकली 93 बाइट्स
की लगभग ये आपकी चंग डेटा हो रही है
बस ये 93 बाइट्स की हो रही है जिसका कि है
यहां पे 5D जो कि हमने वहां पे मेंशन किया
है वी हैव मेंशंड अब यहां पे मैं
डिकोडर पे या कोई भी आप ऑनलाइन भी डिकोडर
वगैरह यूज़ कर सकते हैं। लाइक यू कैन यूज़
हेक्सा डेेसिमल टू डेसिमल या बर्फ शूट में
भी आपको मिल जाता है। तो यहां पे मैं अगर
हेक्स वैल्यू यहां पे लेट्स सपोज़ मैंने
यहां पे
डेसिमल वैल्यू डाली। सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी ये
क्या ये क्या कर रहा हूं यार?
एक्स वैल्यू यहां पे मान लो मैंने 50 कोई
भी एक्स वैल्यू डालूं 56 या व्हाटएवर
एंटिंग हियर तो उसकी एक डेसिमल वैल्यू आ
जाती है। वो डेसिमल वैल्यू वी विल बी
यूजिंग इट। राइट? सो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू यहां पे
यहां पे ये जो डेटा है ये जो डेटा आपकी
यूज़ हो रही है याद रखिएगा ये कंटेंट लेंथ
फाइव हमने यहां पे फाइव यूज़ किया है।
कंटेंट लेंथ हम यहां पे सिक्स डालते हैं।
व्हाट वी विल डू सिक्स ये कैसे होगी यहां
पे?
1 2 3 यहां पे देखो ये काउंटिंग कैसे हो
रही है? उस उस काउंटिंग को थोड़ा सा आपको
ध्यान में देना है। द सिक्स कंटेंट लेंथ।
सो इट विल बी काउंटेड इन अदर वे। इस तरीके
से काउंट नहीं होगा। अब जब यहां पे जब मैं
इसको पूरा का पूरा यहां पे करूंगा तो ये
93 जो आ रही है ये यहां से काउंट नहीं
होती है। दिस विल बी काउंटेड लाइक दिस।
ओनली दिस कंटेंट लेंथ और उसके ऊपर की
डेटा।
यह यहां से काउंट होती है। उसके नीचे का
यह जो डाटा है यह जो आरn 0 आर एन आर एन यह
काउंट नहीं होगा सेकंड रिक्वेस्ट में।
इसका रीज़ क्या है? रीज़ आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा या आना चाहिए अगर नहीं समझ में आ रहा
है तो। हमने एक नई रिक्वेस्ट जी पोस्ट
भेजी है।
हमने एक नई रिक्वेस्ट जी पोस्ट भेजी है।
जिसका हमने कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे जो दिया
है ये अभी ज़ीरो है। ये अभी हमने डिफाइन
नहीं किया भाई। वी हैव नॉट डिफाइंड
एनीथिंग। ये तो हमने अभी ऐसे लगाया है
इसको कि हां भैया यहां पे ये यहां पे
कंटेंट लेंस ज़ीरो था। जो हम नई रिक्वेस्ट
को भेज रहे हैं।
समझ में आ रहा है कुछ? आर यू गेटिंग? हम
तो आर यू गेटिंग
इसको देखो ना वो जी वो कैसे भी 200 हो के
लाना नहीं है यार पहले इधर देखो हमने जो
नई रिक्वेस्ट भेजी थी उसमें हमने कंटेंट
लेंथ ज़ीरो डाला था हमारा कंटेंट लेंथ ज़ीरो
था तो ये जो है ना ये जो चीज है ये जो तीन
नीचे आ रही है ये ये जो जीरो आपकी कंटेंट
लेंथ आ रही है यह जो यहां पे यहां पे यह
जो यह जो टर्मिनेशन हमने की है चंक डाटा
की
यहां पर उस चीज को यहां पर ध्यान दो कि यह
बस एक नोटेशन है। वी हैव दिस जीरो। तो हम
यहां से काउंट करेंगे इस पूरे को तो इट
विल कम 86। इट विल कम 86 काउंट जो कि 56
होता है डेसिमल में। इट डेसिमल में इट
कम्स इट कम्स टू 56।
तो अब हम यहां पे इसको 56 करेंगे। विल डू
56। सो व्हाट विल हैपन नाउ? कि
अब चार जब यह जाएगा रिक्वेस्ट तो फ्रंट
एंड को ट्रांसफर एंड कोडिंग पे 56 यानी कि
यह पूरा का पूरा भेज देगा ये चला गया बैक
एंड सर्वर को और बैक एंड सर्वर के पास जब
जाएगी ये तो बैक एंड सर्वर किस तरह से
इसको करेगा प्रोसेस चार बाइट तो 4 बाइट
कैसे 1 2 3 4 तो यहां पर हमारे पास बच गया
जी पोस्ट
और हम इसको अगर सेंड करेंगे ऐसे तो इट विल
बी 200 ओके
सेंड किया हमने और एक और बार अगर हमने
सेंड किया इसको
तो 200 ओके यहां पे एक और बार सेंड कर गया
यहां पे 200 ओके ही आ रहा है अ
चलो लेट्स सेंड वन मोर टाइम एक और टाइम
सेंड कर लेते हैं क्या जाता है
ओके अरे कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे ज़ीरो डाल
दिया है कंटेंट लेंथ यहां पे ज़ीरो कर दिया
कंटेंट लेंथ अब यहां पे क्या होगा कि 1 2
3 4 5 एंड एक सिक्स जो आएगी दूसरी वाली जो
बाइट आएगी वो सिक्स जो जी पोस्ट वाली
आएगी। राइट? तो यहां पे अब हमें क्या करना
है? सिक्स करना है। कंटेंट लेंथ कंटेंट
लेंथ यहां पे हमें सिक्स कर देना है।
अब हम यहां पे जब इसको सेंड करेंगे, व्हाट
विल हैपन? कि यह कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स को
सेकंड रिक्वेस्ट के लिए कंटेंट लेंथ सिक्स
क्या होगा? 1 2 3 4 5 एंड इसका एक जी
हो गया। जी हमारे पास आ गई पोस्ट हमने तो
रिक्वेस्ट एक नया पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट आ ही
रहा है। तो अब हम इसको सेंड करेंगे। सो इट
विल गिव यू 200 ओके एंड अगेन जब सेंड
करेंगे तो इट विल गिव यू अनरिकॉग्नाइज़्ड
मेथड जी पोस्ट एंड आवर लैब इज नाउ सॉल्वड
इफ यू विल सी
भैया सॉल्व हो जा। यह कौन सा यह देखो
कांग्रेचुलेशंस यू सॉल्व द लैब। सो नाउ
इट्स बीइंग सॉल्व। समझ में आ रहा भैया जी?
समझ में आया आपको?
थोड़ा सा कॉम्प्लेक्स था।
आई नो
थोड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्स था। बहुत लोगों को
कॉम्प्लेक्स लगा होगा। तभी यहां पे आज
बच्चे नहीं है। 27-28 लोग हैं मात्र।
बट अगर आप एक दोबारा देखेंगे वीडियो को
रिकॉर्डिंग को दोबारा देखेंगे थोड़ा नोट
थोड़ा प्रैक्टिस करेंगे थोड़ी लिखेंगे कॉपी
नोटबुक वगैरह में तो आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा। दैट इज़ नॉट एन इशू। यहां पे मेन
पंगा मेन फंडा यहां पे हमारा ये था कि जब
हम इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम एज अ रिक्वेस्ट
इसको देख रहे हैं ना एक न्यू रिक्वेस्ट।
यह हमारा एक न्यू रिक्वेस्ट था। न्यू न्यू
रिक्वेस्ट ऐसे थोड़ी ना होती है। खुद सोचो
ना। न्यू रिक्वेस्ट हमारी इसमें यह 0 n ये
RN ये सब थोड़ी ना आता है।
न्यू रिक्वेस्ट तो न्यू रिक्वेस्ट होती
है। एकदम बिल्कुल ब्रांडेड रिक्वेस्ट होती
है। उसमें कंटेंट जीरो होगा आपका। तो हम
उसी को तो कंसीडर कर रहे थे ना यहां से इस
तरीके से ये वाली ये है ना कंटेंट लेंथ
ज़ीरो वाली रिक्वेस्ट जिसमें बॉडी में कुछ
भी नहीं था।
राइट? ये कुछ इस तरीके का न्यू रिक्वेस्ट
कैसा था? प्रॉक्सी में चल के अगर मैं इसको
सेंड टू रिपीटर करता और यहां पे मैं जाता
तो इसको मैं अगर चेंज करता चेंज रिक्वेस्ट
मेथड टू पोस्ट एंड फालतू के जितने भी
चीजें थी अगर मैं उसको हटा देता यहां से
होस्ट रहने देते हैं।
होस्ट की रिक्वायरमेंट मान लो कि अभी
फिलहाल के लिए नहीं है। तो मैं यहां पे
हटा देता हूं। तो यही तो होती है। कंटेंट
टाइप यह होती। कंटेंट टाइप होता, कंटेंट
लेंथ होता।
यही होता पूरा का पूरा फंडा यही होता। अगर
मैं इसको न्यू लाइन में ऐड कर देता तो कुछ
इस तरीके से यह दिखता
आपकी न्यू रिक्वेस्ट और न्यू रिक्वेस्ट की
जब मैं इसको कॉपी करता कि भैया यह कितने
बाइट का है तो यह 86 का आता। यह 85 आ रही
है। क्यों आ रही है 85? यह आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा। क्योंकि यहां पे
हमने कोई एक चीज मिस करी है। क्या मिस करी
है? वह देखना पड़ेगा हमें।
हां यहां पर एक नया एक जी पोस्ट कर रहे
हैं। हम यहां पर जी पोस्ट सेंड कर रहे
हैं। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। वी आर सेंडिंग जी
पोस्ट एक अ चेंज कर रहे हैं। तो अब यहां
पे जब इसको हम कॉपी करते हैं तो ये 86 आती
इसकी पूरी की पूरी लेंथ। वही लेंथ हमने
वहां पे बताई है। क्योंकि हमारा जो एक नया
रिक्वेस्ट है वो जी पोस्ट जा रहा है। नॉट
जस्ट पोस्ट इट्स जी पोस्ट।
हां जो हमारा सेकंड जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है वह जी पोस्ट के जा रही है ना कि
पोस्ट जा रही है ओनली ओनली पोस्ट होती तो
ऐसे होती बट क्योंकि हम तो यहां जी पोस्ट
भेज रहे हैं ना यही तो सेम चीज है ना जो
मैंने यहां पे कॉपी करके और मान के चलो ये
फर्स्ट वाली में डाल दिया यहां पे जी
पोस्ट
हां सेकंड तो सेकंड का लेंथ हमारा 86 ही
तो है जो हमने यहां पे मेंशन कर दिया है।
86 का जो डेसिमल वैल्यू है 56 है तो 56
हमने मेंशन कर दिया। दैट्स इट। यही तो
हमने काम किया है।
बस 10 दिन 10 दिन 10 दिन यही तो पूरा का
पूरा फंडा था।
अब ये चीज सेम हम एक दूसरे
उसमें इसमें भी कर सकते थे ना। हम इसमें
भी कर सकते थे। एक दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट में हम
ये सेम चीज ला के डाल सकते थे। पहले
रिक्वेस्ट में हम ऐसे करते। दूसरे
रिक्वेस्ट में हम पूरा का पूरा इसको डाल
के इसको यहां से नॉर्मल सेंड करते। उधर कर
देते तो भी हो जाती। मतलब काइंड ऑफ कि अगर
अब अगर आपको दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट में इसको
आपको अगर इसको ऐसे ले जाना होता ना जैसे
यहां से आपको हटाना है। मान लो मुझे यहां
से इसको हटा देना है। मुझे इसमें इस चीज
को प्रोसेस ही नहीं करनी है। तो भी आप उस
सेकंड रिक्वेस्ट में जाके उसको प्रोसेस कर
सकते थे। यू कुड हैव प्रोसेस्ड इट। तो
यहां तक 56 तक आप तो आपकी हो जाती यहां पे
56 जो भी आपकी आती वो वही आपकी होती पूरी
56 करके
कुछ इस तरीके से
आई
आई सी ओनली 5 बाइट्स बट व्हाई रिपीटेड जी
मतलब
नहीं मतलब हमने जी पोस्ट लैब में यहां पर
जैसे लैब में ना इन्होंने क्लियर मेंशन
किया है ना आप देखो ना यहां पे सेकंड
रिस्पांस शुड से अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड जी
पोस्ट तो जी पोस्ट लैब के अकॉर्डिंग हम कर
रहे हैं। लैब में बोला गया है जी पोस्ट
लिखना है। इसलिए हम यहां पे जी पोस्ट लिख
रहे हैं। लैब में बोला गया हो तो कुछ और
पोस्ट लिखना है तो हम कुछ और पोस्ट लिख
देते। अगर लैब में बोला होता तो कुछ और
पोस्ट लिखना है तो कुछ और पोस्ट लिख लेते।
तो लैब में जो लिखा है जो बोला गया है
डालने को जो बोला गया है लैब में करने को
वही हम कर रहे हैं। इसलिए वहां पे हमने जी
पोस्ट लगा दिया। जी हमने कर लिया है।
दैट्स इट और कुछ भी नहीं है। अब यहां पे
डि यहां पे कुछ जी पोस्ट के जगह पे अगर
यहां पे मान लो कि लेट्स सपोज अगर यहां पे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट लगाना होता। ऐसे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट उस केस में ये पूरा का
पूरा चेंज हो जाता। पूरा का पूरा चेंज हो
जाता। चेंज क्यों हो जाती? क्योंकि ये
पूरी लेंथ ही चेंज हो जाती।
ये पूरी की पूरी लेंथ चेंज हो जाती। अब
मैंने यहां पे जी पोस्ट किया।
यहां पे
जी पोस्ट सॉरी क्या हो रहा है यार? ये जी
पोस्ट किया। अब ये इसलिए ऐसे हुआ इसकी
लेंथ। अब यहां पे मान लो डिफ्रॉनिक्स
पोस्ट कर देते हैं।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट ये अगर हमने भेजा तो अब
इसकी लेंथ देखो। अब इसकी लेंथ चेंज हो
जाएगी। इसकी लेंथ कितनी हो गई? 93 हो गई।
अगेन 93 5D पे हो गई। तो अगर हमें यहां पे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट करना है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट तो यहां पे 93 वाली जो
यहां पे हमारे पास वो है 5D वाली। तो इसको
हमें 5D करनी पड़ेगी। वी विल हैव टू चेंज
इट टू 5D।
एंड 5D पे अब करेंगे। अब अगर आप सेंड
करोगे तो यहां पे जो रिस्पांस आएगा
यह तो गेटवे टाइम आउट हो गया क्योंकि यह
लैब का मतलब लैब का जो ये लैब ज्यादा देर
तक खुली होती है तो टाइम आउट हो जाता है
इस वजह से आ गया बट अगर आप यहां पे आगे
करोगे तो यहां पे अब डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट
करके आएगा इंस्टेड ऑफ़ जी पोस्ट ठीक है ये
लैब टाइम आउट इनके तरफ से हो जाती है इस
वजह से ये हो गया तो यहां पे हमने ये लैब
सॉल्व कर दी
राइट हां यहां पे फिर कंटेंट लेंथ भी आपकी
सही बात है यहां पे कंटेंट लेंथ लेंथ भी
आपकी चेंज हो जाती है। कंटेंट लेंथ आपका
फिर चेंज हो जाएगा। बिल्कुल सही। बिल्कुल
सही। कंटेंट लेंथ वुड हैव बीन चेंज्ड।
हां, कंटेंट लेंथ आपकी चेंज हो जाएगी।
कंटेंट लेंथ उसके अकॉर्डिंग हो जाएगी जो
आपकी डिफ्रॉनिक्स पोस्ट करके है ना उसके
अकॉर्डिंग कंटेंट लेंथ हो जाएगी। क्योंकि
पहले जी पोस्ट थी तो छह हमने यहां पे दिया
था क्योंकि हमारा 1 2 3 4 5 और एक उधर से
ले लेता वो छठा
है ना? तो हमारे पास हो जाती सारी फुलफिल।
तो अब ये पूरी
उसकी लेगा। छह के बाद 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 कर लेगा 13 कर लेगा
बस दैट्स इट।
सो ये थी आपकी एक लैब का ओवरव्यू जो कि
आपके टीcl और clt वलेबिलिटी को हमने
एक्सप्लेन करा है। एंड मैं आपको एक बात
गारंटी के साथ कह सकता हूं कि पोर्ट्स
फिगर के ये जो लैब्स है देखो और भी लैब्स
है जब आप इसके सारे लैब्स को ओपन करोगे
तो एचटीटीp रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग के आपको 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
लैब्स मिलेंगे। बट इन लैब्स में जितने भी
आप काम करोगे व्हाटएवर यू विल डू एव्री
लैब हैज़ अ बेसिक कांसेप्ट जो कांसेप्ट
मैंने आपको थ्यरी वाले दिन यानी कि लास्ट
सेशन में 58थ सेशन में बताया था। टोटल 22
लैब है। हां। तो जो थ्योरी में कांसेप्ट
बताया ना वही कांसेप्ट पे ये सारे लैब्स
को आपको सॉल्व करना है। सबका बेस पॉइंट
वही है। हमने यहां पे सिर्फ थोड़े से हमने
शायद एक या दो सॉल्व किए। कौन से सॉल्व
किए थे यार? हां, हमने यहां पे ये दो दो
मेनली हमने यहां पे सॉल्व किया है। clt और
tcl ताकि आपको थोड़ा समझ आ जाए चीजों को।
आपने देखा कि इन दोनों को ही सॉल्व करने
में कितना टाइम लगा क्योंकि आपको समझाना
जरूरी था। अगर आपको समझाऊंगा नहीं तो फिर
वो समझ मतलब वो आपके सर से ऊपर चला जाएगा।
वो मतलब कोई फायदा नहीं है उसको करने का।
कैन आई गेट योर स्लाइड्स? स्लाइड्स का
देखते हैं यार। मैं कुछ करता हूं अगर ऐसा
है तो।
ओके।
तो यह पूरा का पूरा फंडा था। आई होप कि
एवरीवन गॉट दिस थिंग एंड मैं यकीन के साथ
कहता हूं पूरे YouTube पे इतनी डिटेल और
इतना एक-एक चीज को ब्रेकडाउन करके
एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग किसी ने नहीं
बताया है। और हिंदी में अगर आप खोजोगे ना
हिंदी ऑडियंस तब हिंदी लैंग्वेज में तब तो
वो भूल ही जाओ। है ही नहीं। मतलब नॉट
पॉसिबल। अगर आप सम आपको मिलेगा भी तो वो
आपको समझ में नहीं आने वाला है। ये मुझे
पता है। तो इस चीज को वापस रिपीट कीजिएगा।
अ अगर आप नहीं समझ पाए कहीं किसी पॉइंट पे
तो इसको रिपीट कीजिएगा। यहां पे सिंपल सा
हमने किया है। सिंपल सा फंडा है। हम आपको
मतलब एक छोटे से उसमें वो करते हैं समझाते
हैं भैया जी कि एक रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है जो
कि जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट है। दो चीजें हैं
फ्रंट एंड एंड बैक एंड सर्वर। फ्रंट एंड
सर्वर उसको अलग तरीके से डील करेगी। बैक
एंड अलग तरीके से डील करेगी। फ्रंट एंड हो
सकता है कंटेंट लेंथ पे काम करे तो बैक
एंड ट्रांसफर इनकोडिंग पे काम करेगी।
फ्रंट एंड अगर ट्रांसफर एंड कोडिंग पे काम
कर रही है तो बैक एंड कंटेंट लेंथ पे काम
करेगी। अब उन दोनों की वनेबिलिटी यहां पे
फाइंड करनी है कि भैया दोनों में कौन
किससे वनरेबल है। उसके लिए सिंपल स्टार्ट
टाइम आउट वाला प्रोसेस यूज़ करते हैं। जैसे
clt में भी मैंने बताया कि अब एक
रिक्वेस्ट भेजी है कंटेंट लेंथ को वो कर
रहा है प्रायोरिटाइज़। तो कंटेंट लेंथ हमने
सेटअप करके और अगर
ट्रांसफर इन कोडिंग हमने वहां पे जीरो कर
दी तो वो वेट करेगा। अगर हमने वैल्यू बढ़ा
दी। फिर अगर सर्वर के साइड से वेट हो रहा
है मतलब वो वनरेबल है। तो हमने वहां पे
clt में क्या किया? सिंपल उसी तरीके से
हमने अ
उसको अ फाइंड किया कि हां भैया cl.t वन
एबिलिटी है ये।
जहां पर हमने जी पोस्ट मेथड को तो दो
रिक्वेस्ट जाती हैं। एक जेन्युइन
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। एक फर्जी रिक्वेस्ट
जा रही है। मतलब एक स्मगल रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है। तो एक जेन्युइन रिक्वेस्ट से कोई
एक पर्टिकुलर जो चीज है जेन्युइन
रिक्वेस्ट से एक वर्ड है या एक बाइट है वो
सर्वर के पास सर्वर के लॉग में जमा हो जा
रही है। और जब रिक्वेस्ट दूसरी वाली जा
रही है तो वही जो जमा हुई वाली जो जमा जो
हुई है आपके पास जो पर्टिकुलर बाइट वो
उसमें अपेंड हो जा रही है। और मान लो कोई
रिक्वेस्ट एक पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है,
गेट रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है तो पोस्ट जा रही
है। अगर कोई जी नाम का कोई एक बाइट पढ़ा
हुआ है तो जी पोस्ट हो जा रहा है वह और जी
पोस्ट होते ही हमारा सर्वर बोल रहा है
भैया ऐसी कोई मेथड ही नहीं है। तो
अनरिकॉग्नाइज्ड मेथड आ जा रहा है और वही
आपकी इस दोनों लैब की मेन सॉल्व करने की
चीज थी।
आई सी योर वीडियो फ्रॉम 2017-18। ओह ग्रेट
सरलक होम्स थैंक्स ब्रदर।
यस बताइए क्या है?
अ टू थ्री आइडियाज ऑफ़ वीएपीटी प्रोजेक्ट
आईडिया। वीएपीटी प्रोजेक्ट आईडिया देखो
वीएपीटी में बहुत सारे प्रोजेक्ट्स के
आइडियाज तुम निकाल सकते हो। थोड़े बहुत चैट
जीपीटी से पूछ लेना पता चल जाएगा। अब मान
लो कि
लेट्स सपोज़ कि क्योंकि तुम पेन टेस्टिंग
से रिलेटेड कोई भी सी भी प्रोजेक्ट पे काम
करोगे तो थोड़ा बढ़िया प्रोजेक्ट होना
चाहिए। तो इट्स अ काइंड ऑफ कि किसी भी तरह
का इनोवेटिव कुछ अगर कर पाओ तुम बना
तो वो ज्यादा बेटर रहेगा मेरे ख्याल से।
तो कुछ इनोवेटिव टाइप का सोचो। नॉर्मल
कन्वेंशनल तो कुछ नहीं है। थोड़े आईडिया
तुम चैट जीपीटी से और एआई से अपने
कंटेंक्स्ट डाल के लो। क्योंकि अगर जैसे
कोई भी तुम्हें बताएगा ना कि प्रोजेक्ट का
तो वह कहीं ना कहीं चीजें ऑलरेडी चल रही
है तभी आपको बताएगा और ऑलरेडी चलती हुई
चीजें आपको पता चलेंगी। कुछ नया बनाओ तो
फिर कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग लगता है। कुछ बढ़िया
मजे मजेदार होगा। कोई टूल डेवलप कर सकते
हो तुम जो जेरिक पब्लिक यूज़ के लिए
पब्लिक यूज़ कर सकती है। तो इस तरह की
चीजें कर सकते हो।
हनीपॉट बना सकते हो। नो इशज़। एआई बेस्ड
हनीपॉट बना सकते हो। एआई पावर्ड हनीपॉट
बना सकते हो।
अ इस तरीके के एi पाउड स्कैनर बना सकते
हो। सारी चीजें कर सकते हो।
या सो आई होप गाइस दिस ऑल इज़ क्लियर टू यू
एवरीबॉडी। एंड नाउ इट्स टाइम टू एंड दिस।
एंड आई होप कि आपने अ समझ लिया है। आपने
आपको समझ में आ चुकी होगी। यह जो पूरी
अचटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग की पूरी कांसेप्ट थी
इसके ऊपर में जब मैंने आपको समझाया तो वो
लैब के थ्रू भी आपको समझ में आ गया होगा।
एंड डेटा को रीड करने आपको आ गया होगा।
मुझे यह ऐसा फील हो रहा है कि आपको लेंथ
वाली जो डेटा है वो समझ में आ रही होगी कि
कैसे कंटेंट लेंथ को पढ़ा जाता है। यह
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। कैसे कंटेंट लेंथ को
पढ़ा जाता है वो आपको समझ में आ चुका होगा
अभी तक। एंड उसके अकॉर्डिंग आप प्रोसेस कर
लेंगे आराम से। राइट
जो भी आपका सीआर सीआरएलएफ और ये जो न्यू
लाइन वाली जो चीजें थी उसकी मैं बात कर
रहा हूं।
थैंक्स शालिम या जिनको समझ में नहीं आया
उनसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप एक बार रिपीट
कीजिएगा इस वीडियो को। एक बार रिपीट मोड
पे देखिएगा। डेफिनेटली यू विल अंडरस्टैंड
दिस।
नेक्स्ट क्लास बताऊंगा। जल्दी अपडेट
दूंगा। जल्दी थोड़ा करने की कोशिश करूंगा
मैं कि थोड़ी जल्दी ही नेक्स्ट क्लास हो।
नेक्स्ट
हां है। है करेक्ट।
सम हाउ रिलेटेड
ओके।
ठीक है। सो ओके गाइस
सो इस सेशन को यहां पे एंड करते हैं। काफी
लंबी 2ाई घंटे की लगभग सेशन हो चुकी है।
तो अभी काफी लंबा सेशन हो गया। तो इस सेशन
को यहां एंड करते हैं। नेक्स्ट सेशन में
जल्दी मिलेंगे। बहुत जल्द वी विल बी
मीटिंग। एंड अगेन मैं फिर से बोलूंगा कि
WhatsApp जो चैनल है उस पे हमें फॉलो कर
लीजिए। WhatsApp चैनल पे जाके डिफ्रॉनिक
सर्च कीजिएगा या कोई भी वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में हमें WhatsApp चैनल का
लिंक मिल जाएगा। फॉलो कर लीजिएगा फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट और सब कुछ आपको अपडेट जो है सबसे
पहले आपको WhatsApp चैनल पे ही मिलेगी। तो
यह बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। इट शुड बी फॉलोड
बिल्कुल फ्री है। कुछ पैसा आपको नहीं देना
है। चार्ज नहीं देना है। राइट?
थैंक्स आयुष।
काफी अच्छा है। आयुष इज़ सो वेरी मच
इंटरेस्टेड। काफी इंटरेस्ट दिखाते हैं
आयुष जी। अच्छी बात है। आप सब लोग ऐसे
इंटरेस्ट दिखाए तो
सर बग फाइंड करने के लिए आपके चैनल से
क्या देखे बता दीजिए। सिंपल बग बंटी की
प्लेलिस्ट को फॉलो करो। साथ में पैरेलल
में डीई एचई की प्लेलिस्ट है। उसको भी
करो। काली लinिक्स अगर सीखनी है तो काली
लinक्स की प्लेलिस्ट सीख लो। काली लinक्स
में सब कुछ वहां पे आपको बताया गया है।
हाउ टू चूज़ अ टारगेट? इस पे मैंने वीडियो
बनाई है बग बंटी वाली ही। हाउ टू चूज़ अ
टारगेट पे मैंने वीडियो बनाई है। अगर आप
पूछ रहे हैं तो मैं आपको पहले ही बता दूं
कि ऑलरेडी वीडियो हैज़ बीन मेड। इस पे
वीडियो बन चुकी है भैया। तो ऐसा क्यों पूछ
रहे हो यार कि लग रहा है जैसे आपने देखा
ही नहीं है। टारगेट वाली तो वीडियो बनाई
है मैंने यार। देखो मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं। जिसको चाहिए होगा कि हाउ टू चूज़ अ
टारगेट। लाइव में चलते हैं। यहां पे
टारगेट सर्च कर लेना। बग बंटी टारगेट? आई
थिंक वीडियो बनाई थी मैंने इस पे जहां तक
याद है हाउ टू चूज़ द राइट टारगेट फॉर बग
बंटी। राइट? तो जस्ट वॉच दिस वीडियो 1ढ़
घंटे की। ठीक है? थैंक यू सो मच गाइस। हैव
अ गुड नाइट।